[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
be on your side
good luck
amber good luck
babe in uh
good morning
all right the first thing i want to say
is i get a call from my mother last
night and my mother-in-law saying why
did you have your phone on the bench so
i want to clear everything up that was
not my phone
that was a call through the computer
system
because i guess we have an open line for
remote witnesses so that they came
through the computer system jamie says
it's never happened before
came through the computer system and she
hung up on it so just for the record
that was not my phone
so i don't need that kind of grief from
my mother all right
come on
okay
thank you
all right so
i think before the jury comes out we do
have one issue with exhibit
two is it exhibit 548
plaintiffs exhibit 548 okay so you had
offered it to come into evidence
and i know there was an objection
there's a lot of hearsay on it and so
you're
is there a redacted copy for me or is
that something you haven't worked
through
okay
okay that's fine mr two i think it was
her witness but uh
that's fine
well i know it's their exhibit but it's
you're offering it and and so if you're
offering it you have to redact it to
basically i think it says too
well i just wanted to make sure i know
okay if you could work out the details
so uh you owe me one exhibit so we'll
get that at some point today right or
even if i guess tomorrow when i see you
guys that's fine
okay perfect all right anything else
preliminary before the jury mr
rottenborn one brief matter
yes that's fine
okay
are we ready for the jury
yes okay
so
three four five six seven
eight
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen
all right your next witness
two seconds earlier can you get the
screen up i like to get the screen up
before um ladies and gentlemen we
usually try to get the screen up before
you because of that uh the sound but
we'll get it up for you
so
all right
um
i don't know
so
so
so
um
good morning ms james can you please say
your full name
my name is catherine owen james
what's your current address have you
ever spoken with miss vasquez before
today yes
when
i don't recall
what was the substance of that
conversation
i don't recall
was it in the past month
no
was it in the past year
yes
did you talk about this case
no
what did you talk about
i don't recall
if you don't recall how can you recall
that you didn't discuss this case
have you discussed this case or the uk
litigation with mr waldman
i just yes i discussed the uk case with
mr waldman
uh what did you discuss about the uk
case with mr walker your honor can we
can we stop this please okay
i don't have a call you can pause please
no details whatsoever that you recall
yeah
did miss you could there you go
all right you want approach
i'm not sure
ladies and gentlemen in addition to the
video deposition there are some extra
statements that this witness made
um that aren't part of the video but it
is part of her testimony so mr
rottenborn is just going to read those
into the record and for you as well okay
question
have you spoken with adam waldman before
answer yes
question when was the last time you
spoke with him
answer i don't recall
question how many times have you spoken
with him
answer i would say somewhere around 10
times total
question
have you spoken with him in
2022 answer
yes
question what was the substance of that
conversation
answer
friendly banter
question about what
answer nothing to do with the case at
all
question what was it about
answer
we have gotten to know each other
and you know i was on vacation said
happy new year that's it
question did you call him or did he call
you
answer i didn't call him
question did you text him
answer i sent a message saying happy new
year to a lot of my friends
question
over text
answer yes
all right thank you sir all right you
can continue the video
all men assist you in preparing your
witness statements for the uk litigation
no did you
exchange drafts of those statements with
mr
who did you send those drafts to
shillings
is every word in those witness
statements words that you drafted
yes
did anyone provide edits to those
witness statements for your
consideration i'm very good at my own
editing i can assure you
that didn't answer my question did
anyone else provide edits to those
witness statements
now you've spoken with mr depp since he
and amber got divorced correct
correct
when was the last time you spoke with
him
you can answer
i don't
recall was it within the past year no
in any day prior to today have you
exchanged text messages with mr depp yes
when was the last time approximately
that you exchanged text messages with mr
deb
uh
i would say
[Music]
2016
[Music]
oh yeah i think 2016 but it's a long
time ago when was the last time you
spoke with amber heard
i died with colin
was it shortly after
your employment with her ended in 2015
no
was it after that
no
you have you spoken with her to the best
of your recollection or communicated
with her in any way in the past say five
years no
when were you um
when were you hired by mr
in
2012 um how did you meet her
her sister put an ad through a
you know a recruitment
system i use
in my field
um take me through your
the chronology of um
well let me ask you this way when did
you
would you describe your your work for
miss hurt as a personal assistant is
that what you'd call your job title
yes
when did you first start working as a
personal assistant
in 1999
how many for how many people have you
served as a personal assistant
maybe
six
since you
left miss heard's employment in 2015
or how many people have you served as a
personal assistant
one that's the same person i work for to
this day i've been with him for six and
a half years
miss james have you had any other jobs
since other than this
this personal assistant job since you
left miss hurd's employment
no
now your work for miss heard was was it
part time or call time
it started as part-time
when did you change from part-time to
full-time i don't know
what were your job duties
too many to mention
give me your best summary of what your
job duties were please
is this relevant
okay so let's see i mean if you are
ready for a really really long time of
me explaining all of the details that's
fine
it's everything you could possibly do to
run someone's life okay
so it is grocery shopping it is taking
care of admin it is running errands it
is getting the car fixed it is getting
the dogs groomed it is picking up
flowers it is dealing with the decorator
it is dealing with the housekeeper it is
going on and on and on and on and it
goes on every single day
arranging rival dealing with all of the
surplus stuff around the travel booking
all the greeters dealing with the
changing of travel okay liaising with
people that she's working with on films
updating her calendar accordingly uh
liaising with the people on set every
single day to update her calendar to
ensure that she knows what scene she's
doing each day what her call time is all
every day it's something different
but it's a lot of period of myriad of
things that go across the board daily
you were paid for that work correct
very poorly
what were you paid
was it
fifteen hundred dollars a week
to start
i wish my god no it was not she paid me
25 an hour to start off with
and she finally agreed after screaming
abuse of me that she would pay me 50 000
a year once i went to full time and this
was after me working for well over 10
years as a personal assistant so it was
very insulting to me but i did it anyway
because i had grandfathered in the
ability to pick up my son from school
and bring him to work with me at three
o'clock
and you could have left miss herds
employment at any time correct yes
you were based in los angeles when we
were providing personal assistance
services to ms hurd right
i have always lived in los angeles since
1999.
so you didn't travel with miss heard
when she was out of town correct that
was another part about agreement that i
wouldn't travel with her because of my
child
and she was out of town quite a bit
right
not really
not really
how many
weeks a year would you estimate mrs out
of town while you work for
well you're talking uh almost 10 years
ago so i can't tell you quite honestly
but when she was out of town
you wouldn't see
you you you never traveled with her
right no how much did you see uh mr depp
over the course of your employment with
this herd
regularly
how many times
well obviously you didn't see him when
he was out of town right
no
when he was in town
was it would you see him daily weekly
monthly what what would you estimate
there is no rhyme or reason to
to be to answer that question
now
you never witnessed any violence between
this hurd or mr death right no
and misheard never told you that she had
been violent to mr depp correct
no
you had knowledge that um
miss heard and mr depp had
arguments correct
no
miss heard never told you that she
and mr depp had had arguments
occasionally she'd send a text message
complaining about her mental state but
it
was never clear exactly what was going
on
okay so you know
remember she would text me complaining
uh about her mental state and that was
about it i don't have any of the text
messages so it's hard to remember
do you recall hearing anything about uh
an alleged incident between amber and
johnny on a flight from boston to l.a
around this time frame like i said i
remember that day
very well
and and
um
to to follow up on that i'm not asking
just about what amber may have told you
i'm just trying to
drill down generally to
what you may have heard whether from
amber or johnny or anyone
about that
does that make sense
so can you
tell us what do you remember hearing
about
that flight or
what happened or didn't happen on that
flight from boston to l.a
sitting here today you don't remember
anything that you heard about that
i don't know i wasn't on the plane i
just know what happened afterwards
okay
when she asked me to meet her at the
shuttle did you think to ask her if she
was okay
you know i probably did because that's
my role to play a caregiver that's all i
can imagine
so what do you remember about this day
um that you alluded to earlier
mostly my surprise that they went to the
chateau marmont because amber had an
apartment of her own
in west hollywood that was like
completely set up and available to her
so that was my biggest confusion like
why did she go to the chateau
and then she asked me to get her bathing
suit i remember that so i had to go to
her apartment to get her bathing suit
which again seems strange to me
and then
um
what also seemed to change is when i got
there
she had a bunch of friends with her and
it's originally
i thought she was alone
did
when you refer to amber's apartment are
you referring to the apartment on orange
avenue yes yes
and
isn't it true that mr depp
would spend time in that apartment
with amber time to time correct
well i don't really know what the
question is in relationship that he
wasn't there at that time if that's what
you're referring to
yeah no that's not my question my
question was just over the course of
your employment
you have knowledge of mr depp spending
time at that orange avenue apartment
right on there and at his residences i
would go around different practices as
well were you concerned about misheard
and her well-being on this day no
because it did become a pattern with her
and so i was merely replicating her i
would say and especially when i saw she
was there with about four or five
girlfriends and basically having fun
enjoying each other down by the pool
that's why she needed a swimsuit and
then they proceeded to hang there all
day drinking
while i sat around waiting and
with my son actually i think it was a
sunday that day i remember we had to
wait all day and while they just hung
around drinking by the pool
and then
finally i went home
and finally she went back to her
apartment
and then she wanted me to go back and
pack her bag for her at about 10 o'clock
at night on sunday and i said i couldn't
go by that point i'd already spent the
whole day sitting there so i said i
couldn't go and pack her bag because i'd
already put my son to bed and she was
very angry about that i remember that
okay so
let's so when you asked her if she was
okay you didn't actually care if she was
okay you said you were just placating
her right it was a standard standard
procedure at this point she was a very
dramatic person so you
you didn't actually think that there was
anything um
that that amber was actually upset
correct
as i said it just didn't make sense that
she went to the chateau instead of going
home
that was the first for a red flag to
make that time
so so you've so you you came to the
conclusion that day that any
she actually wasn't upset is that what
you're saying it's too much and i've
already answered once
what i'm asking is did you did you come
to the conclusion that
there was nothing wrong with miss heard
that day and that she wasn't actually
upset
such a strange question
like they said you already asked me and
i already answered
i'm asking to answer it again i don't
think i asked the exact same question
but do your best please
could you ask me the question in a
different way or a clearer way that is
not exactly the same as the last
question you could ask me
did you reach the conclusion that day
that miss heard hadn't experienced
anything traumatic
over the course of the day i observed
miss heard enjoying the company of her
friends for several hours that's all i
have to say on that matter
and
would it be odd for someone who's
experienced trauma to want to be around
friend
to you
yeah i don't know
so in any event you you
um you said you sat around at the
chateau marmont is that right
yes well she was deciding what to do
now you were being paid for that time
correct
not overtime it was a sunday
i was not being paid no
did you um
did you avail yourself of anything um at
the hotel like did you order any food
no
did you
i might have ordered some food for my
son actually to be honest now i think
about it because he was only little at
the time
did you would you put that on miss
herd's tab that day
everything was on depth tab that day so
no
on johnny's tab yes let's bring up the
document entitled uh or that ends in six
one five one please trying to agree on
the screen when she wrote i love you and
you wrote lovey too han won't be long x
um
was that just placating misheard
standard friendly text exchange in my
role of work
were you trying to be supportive at all
or or just placating her
both i guess
did you have any concern whatsoever
about miss herd's well-being that day
no
when was the first
time you remember
miss heard
telling you
that um
all wasn't right in the relationship
between her and mr deb
i don't recall exactly when it started
but it was usually
her
complaining and crying uh
due to i would say insecurities within
the relationship more than anything else
she would be very very insecure a lot of
the time and she would call me up crying
i remember one time she called me when
she was alone in new york city and she
was crying walking around the street
crying and he wasn't there she was alone
but i said that she needed to go inside
because i was worried that the paparazzi
might take a photo of her and she was in
a very dysregulated state
and so just out of kindness i i said to
her it was better if she went inside
rather than walking around crying in
public
i remember that but i don't remember
exactly when that was it might have been
2012 or 2013.
um as the um
as the job went on we called each other
less and less and did mostly text
messaging it was all text messaging we
did
did you um
did you ever believe that mr mistreated
her
no
so
and why not
just never any evidence of that at all i
was there
almost daily
in uh both her place and then eventually
at his place in west hollywood and then
ultimately at
the lost downtown
it was a daily basis experience morning
moon night
all days of the week so you know i mean
i never once saw any evidence of
anything
did miss her ever tell you that
johnny had hit her
did he ever tell did she ever tell you
that johnny had pulled her hair
or pushed her
no
let me ask you a little bit differently
you never believed
misheard that mr depp had mistreated her
is that correct
at the time or after
i never believed in what context are you
talking about
during my employ or afterwards
and there was never any damage to the
apartment that i witnessed there was
never any aftermath of anything ever
that i ever saw
now you of course
have no personal knowledge one way or
the other whether
um johnny was abusive to her correct
well i don't know if that's necessarily
true because if it was true i would have
seen the damage even if i wasn't
physically present in the moment of
these alleged arguments
and what's your basis for that statement
well if someone's been foundation
there's generally physical evidence
so your testimony is that if there's if
if there was no physical evidence that
you observed then it couldn't have
happened the domestic violence by johnny
toward amber is that your testimony
no
well i'm trying to to understand what
your testimony is um maybe you could
clarify for me miss james um it is your
testimony that um
he never saw
firsthand evidence of johnny being
violent to amber that it couldn't have
happened
that's not what i said you're trying to
put words into my mouth i don't
appreciate that can you pull up the
document that is um
well let me see what it ends with here
i'll direct your attention to the um
okay
this is this is a document that um
the corresponding file exhibit you could
just bear with us for one minute um and
then we'd like to
move for admission all right what's the
number on it that's what we're trying to
do okay
all right and that's defendants844
yes ma'am okay eight four four any
objection to eight four four
all right if you want to approach
then if somebody has a copy of 844 for
me
oh we'll we'll get it we'll we'll get it
that's all right we'll get it
can you just wait one minute
yes thanks
box at the bottom
do you see your name kate in that um the
column labeled participants yeah
is this a text message that you received
from mr depp um on around august 13th
2016. yes
and
it appears that he's responding to
something that you had sent him correct
i don't know
you see where he says thank you
sweetheart
yes
he's directing that to you right it
looks like there's someone else see seed
on this text so it could be to that
person i honestly don't know i can't
answer your question can we please pause
the video all right can you pause for a
second
thank you he already did that was good
thank you nice work
that um we'll switch to our okay
not yet but no not yet
all right and your honor with the
um
with the stipulation that we'll prepare
a redacted version to be entered into
evidence
that has other personal identifiers
redacted we'd ask for permission to
publish to admit this into evidence and
publish to the jury
the objections are noted
and we'll get the redacted copy all
right thank you your honor
you just blow it up heather
oh
ready to resume with the video thank you
your honor
do you see where he says um we'll hit
you when i get back doll come over for a
spot of purple and we'll fix her flabby
ass nice and good yep
um
come over for a spot of purple means
come over for a drink of wine right i
don't know
that's what you understood it to me
correct
i don't know
solution can you pull up the documents
um
labeled uk trial day seven james
testimony please
and miss james you remember giving
testimony in the trial in the uk right
uh well there'd be something wrong with
me if i didn't
and
you need order in the corner you gave
that testimony you gave it under oath
correct
yes
um
lucian can you please go to page 39 of
the pdf
and can you please blow up
the page that is labeled 1221.
and on line seven um miss james is it am
i reading this right you were asked a
question and he is inviting you over for
a spot of purple what is that
yes your answer question what did you
understand
and you answered red wine i imagine you
see that
yeah i do remind about
remember giving that testimony
so is it your understanding that mr depp
was inviting you over for um for wine
um at some point after he split up or
misheard and just speculation
did you go did you meet up with mr depp
um for
red wine
around the time period of this text on
august 13th 2016. i did meet up with him
but we did not drink red wine
[Music]
was anyone else present for that meeting
no
when he said come over for a spot of
purple and we'll fix her flabby ass
you understood him to be referring to
miss her when he
said we'll fix her flabby ass correct
yeah it wasn't for me to speculate what
she what he was referring to
and i'm not asking for you to speculate
what he was referring to i'm asking for
your your understanding
was that he was talking to miss
you can answer
there isn't an answer i mean this is the
way he writes it's very random and you
don't sort of question it okay it's just
the way he writes he writes in a very
abstract way
okay um lucian if you can just pull up
the prior testimony that we just looked
at
miss james um isn't it true that
on line 12 of page 1221 you were asked
the question red wine and not only to
come over for a spot of purple but to
fix her flabby ass that was about
misheard was it not and on line 14 you
answered yes yes do you see that
yes
so you did understand this to be
referring to
correct
i'm sorry you said
no just trying to be agreeable in the in
the court having no clue what on earth
is going on so there you go
was that answer in the court
truthful or just agreeable just being
agreeable
so it wasn't truthful
you can answer
i don't have an answer for you
what did you and mr depp talk about at
that meeting
that you recall
i don't look for details
just tell me generally everything you
recall
it's too long ago mr rottenborn i don't
recall
do you recall anything
no
where was the meeting
auntie's residence in west hollywood
is that
what i'm sorry west hollywood
what time of day
um
about 3pm
um so you recall the time of day but you
don't recall anything you discussed
well i'm just saying i know it was in
the afternoon because it was after i
picked my son up from school because my
son went to swing in the pool with the
security guards watching him while i
went and had a brief conversation with
mr deck that's the only reason i
remember the time
did you talk about miss hurt
yes
what did what did you discuss about mr
uh
and like i said i don't recall the
details
well i'm i'm just a little confused
because you just satisfied you didn't
remember anything but now you remember
that you did talk about miss herds and
what i'm trying to get is everything you
remember about the conversation well
you've got to understand mr rottenborn
the the mutual um connection between mr
deck and myself is in fact mr misheard
so inevitably that is going to be part
of the conversation that's all i
remember
okay do you remember anything else about
that conversation with mr depp
have you seen mr deb since that
conversation
now
um
what's your
just describe generally your educational
background please
i completed high school and then i went
straight into becoming a veterinary
nurse when i left at school left school
which i did for
approximately three to four years before
i left australia
do you have any sort of specialized
training in veterinary medicine or
nursing
only on the ground experience four years
in a clinic
so um
you don't have any experience with um
medical training for humans right
and um you don't have any training in
health care correct
could you be more specific
you don't have any training in health
care for people correct
i'm not enough i'm not a human nurse if
that's your question i don't really
understand your question
sorry you don't have any training
related to prescription drugs do you
no
and um you have no idea
excuse me only pertaining to animals yes
i would like to add that
okay and that that was the training that
you received on the job in australia
before you came to the us
amongst other things yeah
um
you
familiar with
ms heard
taking
prescriptions for acne and pro vigil
among other things correct injection
you are not um
you never served as a nurse or a doctor
to misheard right
no
and
you have uh no medical knowledge um
to testify whether
uh miss heard used pro vigil or accutane
in the way her doctor's instructed
correct
no
and you're not an expert on the
interaction of prescription drugs and
alcohol or other drugs correct
now
did you during the course of your
employment develop any personal
knowledge of
mr depp's use of alcohol or drugs
not firsthand
and what do you mean by not firsthand
well i worked at amber i didn't work
with him
did you ever see mr depp
using
illegal drugs
no
did you ever see mr depp um
abuse alcohol
no did you ever speak with dr kipper
no did you ever speak with aaron borham
yeah
and aaron borem was a nurse who worked
for dr kipper right
he was assigned to amber
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
she was assigned to amber that's how i
came to be speaking to her
and she also provided medical services
to johnny right
i i don't know
what do you recall speaking to aaron
gorham about
just random chit chat in the course of
the day nothing specific
do you recall ever forming any concern
in your own mind about any of mr depp's
behavior in his relationship with amber
nothing you heard
nothing you witnessed nothing you saw
during your time with missouri ever gave
you an inkling of concern about mr
depp's behavior toward amber
now
you
um
you left your employment
your your employment with amber ended
in early 2015 correct
you know just after they came back from
the wedding on the island
did miss herd terminate your employment
when miss heard came back from the
island she informed me that she now
needed to support her mother because her
mother could no longer work after a
diagnosis a medical diagnosis and she
told me she could no longer afford to
pay me since she had to support her
mother and therefore she would have to
terminate my employment to support her
family
and did you resent miss herd for that
for terminating your employment
i would have been nice to have been
given some notice so i had some time to
look around uh so i was a little upset
for the lack of notice
but apart from that no i was not upset
i gave you six weeks of severance pay
correct
i don't nicole
you want to stay in the job for misheard
well i did ask if i could have a few
months heads up so i could seek another
job that would suit the terms of my
employment but she did not allow that
and that made you angry correct
no
did did you ask to be put on mr depp's
payroll so that you could remain uh
being paid by misheard or mr deb well
when she said she couldn't afford i said
now you're married couldn't i go on to
uh dep's payroll and she said no it was
part of a legal agreement i had that she
was not allowed to do that i don't know
whether that was true or not
you ever asked mr depp whether you could
go on his payroll
no
isn't it true that you asked to
live in one of mr depp's houses rent
free for a period of time after your
employment well you see i'm a homeowner
and but i want to be clear
i didn't want to miss a mortgage payment
due to unemployment so my idea was is
perhaps i could find an alternate
accommodation in order to rent out my
house so i don't lose my entire property
i'm a homeowner keeping my home and my
payments up to date is that
paramount importance to me
isn't it true that you had already
skipped about a year and a half of
mortgage payments on your home during
the time you were employed by miss hurt
no
let's pull up the document ending in alh
5858 please
exhibit
11 on the screen
yeah i think i can i think you've read
everything um
so if you're if you're ready for me to
ask you questions my first question is
just is this an email exchange between
you and amber relating to the
termination of your employment yeah this
is the email i received when she
terminated me
and then the emails above that in this
document are some of which are
duplicated are an email exchange that
you had with amber
after you received the termination email
yeah when i woke up that morning yeah
um can you go to the first page please
top of the document
isn't it true that
miss her did pay you
six extra weeks of pay after your
termination
she's stating that but i don't recall if
it actually happened or not
you don't have
personal knowledge one way or the other
or a recollection of whether she did
no
um
and
isn't it true that you you do tell her
in this email that you didn't pay your
mortgage for the first year and a half
that you were working for her
yes i had one of those balloon mortgages
so i had to go through a loan
modification and i recall now that
that's why i was able to agree to work
for her for such a small amount of money
than what i normally made it was sort of
as a
favor almost
what what was the favor
it worked for her for like half my usual
paycheck basically
so you're you were doing amber a favor
yes because initially it was described
as a part-time 20-hour a week thing for
flexibility and blah blah blah so
you know i thought it's not really in my
caliber but my son was only four at the
time so it seemed like a good idea
especially because i wasn't paying my
mortgage so i could take the hit by
getting
less pay than i would normally make
and that way i could also have the time
with my son that i wanted
and i think the answer to this is no but
i just want to be clear you're not
blaming amber for you're not paying your
mortgage right
no that was my choice
that was the only way i could get a loan
modification
was the way it worked
but you know the 2008 crash that's how
it worked back then if you wanted to
save property
and you started working for amber in
2012 right
yes it took a long time with one
modification process
and and
you're not blaming amber for getting a
credit card with 29 interest are you
what
you see in your email on that first page
um about two-thirds of the way down you
say i have borrowed from my mom my
tenant security deposit and now i have
used up a credit card i should use as it
has 29 interest
oh that's my choice
did you have tenants in your property at
that time
i have a duplex i'm just trying and that
time yes i had tenants in one house and
i was living in the other
did you use those tenants security
deposit for personal expenses
i don't remember
do you see where you say i have borrowed
from my mom my tenant's security deposit
does
do you recall using your tenant security
deposit or borrowing from that
it's too long ago for me to recall if it
actually happened
would there be a reason that you would
have
said that if it wasn't true
no
and um isn't it true that you did ask to
live rent-free
um
in
johnny's houses
after you were terminated right
lots of people
did isn't true that you did
yes
and did that ever come to pass
no
did it make you angry that that didn't
happen
no
it's fair to say at the time that your
employment was terminated you were in
fairly significant financial trouble
correct
yes
and
you were angry with amber for
terminating you at this time when you
were in financial trouble correct
no
you see at the bottom of your email on
page two
you say
max and i love you very much
as a sign off to your email yes
and max is your son right yes
that wasn't true
correct in fact you you didn't love
amber you didn't like her did you um any
close relationship has ebbs and flows
and the energy that you feel towards one
another it's pretty standard
and at that point in time
you
um well since your termination
you've had nothing but animosity toward
misheard correct
no i actually bumped into her at the p.o
box
about three months after and she was in
her range rover and i
saw her sister and she said come say hi
to amber and i went back there and i was
going to say hi but she was on the phone
and she was saying wait wait but then i
had to go that's the only time i've ever
seen her but i wanted to go and say hi i
wasn't feeling like i wanted to avoid
her or anything
you know things things happen and life
goes on you know
i understand you're a personal assistant
miss james what type of people do you
work for
uh
high profile celebrities
are they
celebrities in the entertainment
industry yes
you previously testified that in march
of 2012 you worked as a personal
assistant for miss heard yes
yes
in total how long did you work for miss
hurt as her personal assistant
almost three years
and at the time you were hired in march
of 2012 had you ever heard of miss heard
no
you previously testified today that at
some point while working from his heart
you transitioned from working part-time
to full-time is that right
when did that transition happen
i don't recall specifically
you think it happened within the first
year of your employment i believe it
happened within the
around six months into the employment
so most definitely it happened
in the first year of your employment is
that correct yes
you really testified that you stopped
working for ms hurd as her personal
assistant in february of 2015. is that
right yes
and you also testified that ms heard let
you go upon her return from the bahamas
in february of 2015. yes
yes
did miss herd ever give you any
indication or warning that your
employment might end upon her marriage
to mr depp
how did it make you feel when miss heard
terminated your employment without
warning
a bit of a shock a bit of a feeling of
being blindsided
when you first began working for miss
heard
and when miss heard was in town
in other words not traveling how many
times per week would you see her
almost daily
and did that change when you became a
full-time
personal assistant for ms heard
no
would you see miss hurt on the weekends
as well
yes
and when you would see miss hurt in
person did you coordinate with her when
you would be
seeing her
no i would arrive whenever it was
necessary to bring stuff that i'd picked
up on errands or whatnot there was no
given that schedule
and when you said you would arrive where
would you arrive to
um it depended where she was at the time
sometimes she was at orange sometimes
she was at one of johnny's houses on the
sweet sir and then eventually they all
moved down to the lofts downtown you
previously testified that your work as
miss hurts
as being miss heard's
private assistant
was extensive would you please tell us
everything that was you were responsible
for
everything from handling all of her
dry cleaning
packages mail liaising with agents
other people in the industry
coordinating travel
making restaurant reservations uh
you know dealing with the staff the
vendors on the property
that sort of thing
did ms heard ever ask you to
monitor press for her
yes
what specifically did she ask you to do
i had a newsstand guy that was
instructed to hold two couples of every
magazine she appeared in uh
was a newsstand on sherborne avenue just
off la cienega and he would hold them
for me and i would go there once
magazines i'm sorry you you got muffled
out you said and he would hold those for
me and hold them for me and i would go
approximately once a week to pick up
whatever magazines amber was featured in
two copies of each
which i would then store in her garage
why would you store them in miss heard's
garage
because she didn't want mr deb to see
them
did she tell you why she didn't want mr
duff to see them
no she just got very angry with me one
day because i hadn't quite made that
made it downstairs to put them in the
garage when she came home and she went
absolutely ballistic over that
when you say she went absolutely
ballistic over that can you please
describe what you mean
blaming yelling abuse
do you remember what she said to you
no
but it was abusive in your opinion
rage
over the three-year period in which you
worked for miss heard were you ever with
miss heard when she was getting dressed
or undressing
all the time
how often were you present when miss
heard was getting dressed
every time she was getting dressed for a
fitting i was i would say 90 percent of
the time i was there
and just to clarify was it just when
miss heard was in fittings that you
would see her in states of undress
no it was it was also in her apartment
she had no issue with walking around
naked quite often
did you ever observe miss heard putting
on makeup
yes how often did you see miss her doing
her makeup
just when she was getting ready to go
out somewhere for a party or something
and when you interacted with miss heard
and i understand it was quite
frequent and regular
did it appear to you that she was
wearing makeup
you usually never wore makeup unless she
was going to a special event
and when she did go to special events
would you describe her makeup as heavy
it would definitely
it would my makeup artist would do it or
if she would do it herself if she did it
herself it would be light and usually
adding lashes and that's about it
and i believe you previously testified
to this so i'm sorry for asking you
again but while you worked for miss her
did you ever see any types of injuries
on her
no
did you ever see any cuts
no
did you see bruises
did you see swelling
redness in her face
no
how about misheard having black eyes no
though a broken nose
missing hair clumps
i'm sorry i didn't catch that
stream
did you ever see miss her cry
yes
how often did you see her cry
hard to put a number on it sometimes she
would cry on the phone i think at least
once or twice she might have cried on
the phone
you know and then as far as seeing her
personally crying you know she was a
pretty dramatic person it's hard to
really put a number on it
i'm focusing on when you saw her in
person crying
how many times do you believe
that you saw her in person crying
i would say twice maybe twice
let's take that in in bite sizes the
first time you saw miss her in person do
you recall what she was crying about
go ahead miss james
insecure emotions
so the twi the two times that you recall
miss heard crying in front of you
you remember her crying about being
insecure is that correct
you testified that
she felt insecure about her relationship
is that correct yes
can you expand on that
what do you mean by that
he didn't like being away from his
physical presence
did she miss her tell you that she felt
insecure when mr death
wouldn't be
present with her
other than telling you she felt insecure
about her relationship with mr deb
what else did miss heard say
about feeling insecure
she told me she didn't like hanging out
in his house with his friends because it
it was boring and they were all old men
playing guitars and it wasn't
interesting to her
was miss her dating mr depp when you
first started working for her
yes
when did you first learn that miss heard
was dating mr duff
after uh about a month i think
how did you learn that she was dating mr
duff
she told me
what did she tell you
she
she told me she was dating johnny depp
do you recall the first time you met mr
duff
yes
when was that
it was in her apartment on orange
probably shortly after she told me she
was dating him he was standing in the
dining room
and approximately when was that
i don't remember i would say
april april or may of 2012.
what was your impression of mr duff
he was very peaceful very calm almost
shy and uh very quiet
and i remember he was wearing red red
suede shoes because i didn't know where
else to look i looked at his shoes
it's a weird recollection i know
i was being honest
did you ever witness mr depp be rude to
anyone
he's such a gentleman he's so he's like
a total southern gentleman
did you ever see mr dapp
lose his cool
no did you ever see him screaming anyone
did you ever see him break something
only in a video in your presence
did you ever see mr depp break something
intentionally never break anything never
throw anything always completely passive
i believe you've testified previously
but you have a son correct yes
how old was your son when you first
started working for ms hard
four four years old
and did you ever bring your son
to work with you yes
how often
uh
quite often if i had to keep working i
would bring him back there after school
and if i had to work on the weekends he
would come with me then
did mr depp ever interact with your son
yes he was very kind
how often did you did mr depp interact
with your son
whenever they were in each other's
presence
can you give me an estimate of how often
that
happened
oh countless times and he would he would
even teach him how to play guitar
he brought him back
vacations
uh
he showed him his amazing makeup
makeover when he was doing black mass he
tricked him he went over and was saying
do you know who i am like a full makeup
son's jaw almost hit the ground it was
really cute actually
he gave my son a
little um
kick as well a guitar pick which he
cherishes to this guy as well
fair to say you were around mr depp and
this hurt together
quite a quite a lot
yeah it became increasingly more as the
time went on yeah
what was your impression of misheard and
mr depp's relationship
you know it was it did not seem like a
perfect relationship to me based on a
lot of insecurity on her behalf
which seemed to cause uh
confusion in the relationship
um
maybe the age gap was an issue because
it interests i know that much
apart from that who am i to know the
relationship you know
do you think that mr depp was smothering
of misheard
did it did it appear to you that mr depp
was jealous of misheard
no
did you ever have interactions with mr
depp
by yourself um
sometimes yeah
and what were those
interactions like this friendly chit
chat which would stop immediately when
amber saw me speaking to him she'd give
me the evil eye and i'd know to just
quickly walk away
did amber ever talk to you about your
interactions with mr depp
no
in the three years that you worked for
miss heard did you ever see miss hurd
and mr deb argue
no
in the three years yet that you worked
from miss heard
did you ever see any physical violence
between miss hurt and mr deb
neville did you ever see
either of them being physically
aggressive with one another no
did you ever see any property damage at
miss heard's home
no no
did you ever see any property damage
at mr depp's primary residence on sweets
did you ever see any property damage at
the lofts or the penthouses of the
eastern columbia building
no never
over the three-year period in which you
worked for him has heard did you ever
hear from anyone that mr depp
or ms hurd had been in a physical
alteration altercation
no over the three-year period in which
you worked for ms heard did you ever see
ms hurd be physically aggressive with
anyone
no
let's break that down a bit when you say
she was verbally abusive to you
regularly
can you
explain to me
how she was verbally abusive to you
screaming
uh
screaming over the phone she screamed at
me once in person
multiple times screaming at me over the
phone barrages of abusive
text messages
day and night a lot of them in the
middle of the night i think you're aware
i think uh
between two and four am the barrage
would start that's what i'd wake up to
um all incoherent not really making
sense just basically someone to lash out
at you know no apparent reason to it
you testified previously that you
observed miss heard be verbally abusive
to her sister
yeah what do you recall about that it
was
ongoing it kick the dog kind of
relationship with her sister so it's
really hard to pinpoint any specifics
but
uh yeah uh her poor sister was treated
like the dog that you kick basically
you previously testified that miss heard
you observe has heard be verbally
abusive to her mother
what specifically did you observe
well there is a video that um
line where you can see her being abusive
first and foremost so it's not even
based on what i'm telling you it's what
i've seen the interactions between the
two of them when her mother was still
alive and the fact that her mother was
terrified of her
did her mother tell you she was
terrified of her you personally told me
what's
did you ever
witness miss heard
tongue lash her mother
here and there yes
especially when it was uh build up to a
stressful event or something like that
yeah
you said you felt that miss hurd was
verbally abusive to you
can you provide me with any specific
examples
of this behavior
well i thought i did earlier but yeah it
was just
so random and ongoing you would never
know where when it was going to come
left of center um i do remember on one
occasion when we were moving from part
to full time and then the salary
negotiations became a real loan of
contention and i specifically remember
standing in her office where she leapt
up out of her chair put her face epox
approximately
four inches from my face as she was
spinning in my face and it's telling me
how dare i ask for the salary i was
asking for which was in fact
approximately half of my regular annual
salary i was offering her that as a
favor
and she felt
she felt that go her the right to spit
in my face
and there was a witness in the apartment
at that time by the way
who was at the apartment at the time the
handyman hector galindo
i'm sorry but handyman hector galindo
he was so
he was so mortified he was so
embarrassed to hear her speaking to me
like that
miss james while you worked for miss
heard did you ever observe her drinking
alcohol
yes i did
how often
did you observe miss heard drink alcohol
don't recall
what alcohol did you observe miss her
drink and your presence
did miss herd ever
appear intoxicated to you
yes she often did
well you worked for miss heard were you
aware
what if any prescription drugs she was
taking yes because i had to pick it up
and i often had to deliver it to her
anticipated
i'm sorry ms james i interrupted your
question or your answer excuse me
the last part of your answer was to
i would it was my job to pick it up
and deliver it to her also bring it to
her if she was doing a photo shoot or
you know on set or something
if she'd forgotten it
what prescription drugs
do you remember
picking up from this hurd
provincial
any other prescription drugs that you
remember picking up from his herd
accutane
any others
not specifically
to your knowledge
did miss herd ever stop taking providual
or accutane while you were working for
her
no
did miss her ever tell you that she had
was experiencing any side effects from
provisional
she didn't say it but i observed it
we'll go back to that in a minute but
didn't miss hurt ever tell you that she
was experiencing any side effects from
accutane
no
you previously testified that you
observed misheard having certain side
effects from per visual
yes
yes
what side effects did you observe miss
heard exhibiting
manic
episodes
can you tell me what you mean by manic
episodes
similar to if someone was on some sort
of amphetamine drug
moving very fast
not making a lot of sense
hyper organizing hypertasking
just very very
hyper
besides prescribed medication did you
ever observe ms hurt and just any
illicit drugs while you worked for her
no
didn't miss her ever tell you that she
had ingested illegal drugs
yes
when did miss her tell you that she
had ingested illegal drugs
um
sporadically here
what drugs did miss her tell you she had
ingested
mushrooms
ecstasy
and cocaine
if you remember how many times did miss
heard tell you that she had ingested
illegal drugs
i can't remember
based on your personal observations did
it ever appear to you that ms heard was
under the influence of illegal drugs
yes
how many times
uh i don't know
less than five
so long ago it's hard for me to remember
why did you
why did it appear to you that miss heard
was under the influence of illegal drugs
disoriented partying with friends
lots of heavy drinking laughing dancing
playing
all the sorts of things that go hand in
hand with
imbibing in drugs
would miss herd's treatment of you
change
when she was intoxicated
yes
how so
she became more and more belligerent
ms james you previously testified that
you provided testimony in the matter
involving mr depp in the united kingdom
do you remember that testimony
yep
and how did you provide testimony in the
united kingdom
uh well i wrote a witness statement and
then i had to do a live video feed
and did you understand that your witness
statement was made under o
yes
and did you understand that your
testimony during the trial live was also
under oath
did anyone help you write your witness
statement
uh
schillings over in the uk
helped me with the first draft and then
i took over and
completely edited it to be my own words
that was after a phone conversation we
had
they jotted down notes sent me some
basic notes to work with and then i
worked on it from
there how long did it take you to write
your witness statement
um about three or four days
did you feel you had an adequate amount
of time to prepare and write your
witness statement yes i was very proud
with the outcome of how i wrote it
because it was all my words and it was
the absolute truth
and did you have enough time to review
your witness statement for accuracy
before you signed it
yes
was everything that was in your witness
statement true and accurate to the best
of your knowledge
yes
and is that still true today
mayor please have you pull up exhibit
dap exhibit number four please join
depth exhibit our forum screen
thank you
miss james do you remember receiving an
email from miss heard
on or about february 2
12 2015.
i don't even believe i was still working
late
do you remember receiving this email in
particular from
february 12 2015.
again i don't as far as i know it wasn't
even working for her at that time so i
wouldn't even know why she wrote this
to me quite on the same
do you remember receiving this email
then
can we please pull up exhibit number
five
on the screen
let's see may i ask you to there you go
you read my mind
lucy and may either take control or have
you scroll down to the bottom
thank you
games
the way these emails tend to work is
they they start at the bottom
and then go up
and this one is no exception
so i'm going to
for your
ease i'm going to have you read the
bottom email first since it's the first
one in the chain dated february 3rd 2015
[Music]
she was traveling straight to london
after the wedding that's what that's
what i'm reading
do you remember
actually you know what why don't you
read this entire email chain and then
i'm going to ask you some questions
about it
right now
this
can you help me uh oh no no it's moving
i don't know it's being finicky
i do have control
sorry miss james
[Music]
do you remember receiving these emails
from miss heard
not really no
no
do you see where miss heard on
february 4th 2015 writes in all caps
are there no direct flights
chinmark question mark exclamation
i'm just pointing her to the top email
mr rottenborn do you see where
miss heard
writes to you
are there no direct flights in all caps
you would agree with me that
nowhere else in this email chain miss
heard uses all caps just to write to you
correct
no that's not
she seems very confused that's all i can
say when i'm reading through this she
just seems to be very confused
and the thing is um
like if that if that question were to be
directed to anyone it should have been
to the travel agent not me i mean i'm
not the travel agent
the travel agent was down there in the
beginning
trudy sullivan directing your attention
miss james to may
of 2014
when you met
miss heard at the chateau marmont in los
angeles california do you remember your
testimony about that
incident
you testified previously that she
that miss heard asked you to bring a
bathing suit to the hotel is that
correct
yes
did you see ms hurd wearing
a bathing suit
in may of 2014 at the chateau marmont
yes
based on your recollection did you see
any bruises on misford's body
did you see any red marks on miss herd's
body no
how would you describe the general
atmosphere
or mood of miss heard and her friends at
the chateau marmont but to be honest it
seemed a little conspiratorial to me
how so
like a strategy meeting or something and
combined with a pool party hard to
describe
it was very confusing originally i
thought i was going over for some major
emergency but then something else
completely different was going on that
day
what made you think something
completely different was going on that
day
well because originally it made it seem
like she was having this major emergency
and she was completely alone and she
needed me very badly to come as quickly
as possible but when i got there she was
surrounded by people
savannah io till it right and rocky
specifically racquel pennington
what was the second name you said i got
rocky and who
i o till it write it's the letter i the
letter o
till it right
did you observe miss heard showing what
appeared to be injuries to
any of her friends at the chateau that
day
no
did it appear to you
that ms heard's friends were con
comforting her
how would you describe miss hurt's
friend's behavior
hanging out together by the pool having
cocktails and spending the entire
afternoon hanging around together
did you ever
[Music]
did you ever learn information that made
you believe that
one of the reasons that their
relationship uh between johnny and amber
wasn't as you described perfect was
because of johnny's substance abuse
i couldn't speculate on the details of
their personal relationship
you did testify earlier that one of the
reasons you thought their relationship
was wasn't perfect was insecurity on
amber's part though right
yes
so you you developed an opinion that
insecurity on amber's part affected
their relationship but you did not
develop an opinion that substance abuse
or any actions by johnny affected their
relationship is that right that
statement was based on communications
directed to me from amber basically
what communication specifically
expressing uh you know exactly what i
just stated
that she was sad she didn't want to be
away from him
blah blah blah that sort of thing
that would happen all the time
and um
you believe that those statements
were the reason that their relationship
wasn't perfect
it's not for me to speculate
you would agree that
it's because someone is insecure in a
relationship does not
mean that she deserves to be abused
correct
i have no answer for you for that
you would agree that
even if someone acts quote unquote
smothering in a relationship doesn't
mean she deserves to be abused correct
i do not have an answer for you for that
i don't have any further questions thank
you for your time today
all right thank you all right ladies and
gentlemen let's go ahead and take our
morning recess for 15 minutes no outside
research do not talk about the case
right okay thank you
again
all right let's go ahead and take a
break until noon
um it is your next witness um
we're going to set it up so it's all
ready to go in the next okay i really
appreciate that okay thank you we'll be
in recess until now
so
laurel avis anderson
and what is your business address
[Music]
it's been a while 109 21
wilshire boulevard
westwood medical plaza suite one
one one zero one los angeles
90024. and you're a clinical
psychologist is that correct
correct
and you practice in los angeles
yes
for how long have you been practicing
almost 40 years
have you been practicing in los angeles
for that entire time yes
and you provide counseling for couples
psychotherapy for individuals and
couples
and what is psychotherapy
just a brief layman's
description
um it's an evaluation of an individual
or a couple's
problems
and then it's a
conceptualization of what's actually
going on and an effort to make
intervention that leads to change do you
recognize what this document is yes
what is it
uh this is my ledger for tracking
sessions
that i use for
invoice billing and did this ledger come
out of your files
yes
and you keep this document in the
ordinary course of business
absolutely
and i just want to um
in this particular ledger who is it for
it's well despite the names that are
camouflaged um it's for ms heard and mr
depp
at the top um
what what are the two names that it says
there ann henry and joey davis
and ann henry's amber
yes and joey davis is johnny depp
yes
and then it and then uh it says age 29
and 52 is that right yes
and 29 was the age of amber heard at the
time yes and 52 was the age of johnny
depp yes so so as i understand it
on october 1st
2015
mr depp and amber heard came in for
couples counseling at uh for three and a
half hours
yes
whether they were in for the full three
and a half or not i don't know
but that was the amount of that was when
this the session started and they came
in when they came in and
not together um and it took three and a
half hours to actually do that for a
session
so as i understand it for that first
session
mr depp and amber did not come in
together
i don't believe that they did the next
session
with amber with miss heard alone
for
background intake
and that was a two and one third hour
session
and that session was on october 6 2015
yes
and what's the next row
you saw amber on october 6 2015 for two
and a third hours correct
yes
and what is the next row indicating
the next day october 7th mr depp for
three and a half
again it may not have been
face to face for the full three and a
half
but it was
being at the beginning of the session
waiting for him his coming in with the
entourage and
are getting to work
and
for the the three sessions we just
discussed the the october 1st session
the october 6th session and the october
7th session
those are all in person with you correct
so yes the first three sessions were all
in person
and then what does it say under
for the next row for the 1014 row
couple
three hours
so on october 14th 2015 amber heard and
mr depp
saw you for a couple session
yes
there's a there's a couple session on
october 14th for three hours is that
right 10 14 there's a couple session on
10 21 there's a couple session
where someone walked out
for two hours on 10 24 miss heard was
there we did a phone session for one and
a half
and and how did
and
on the 10 24 row
next to the two hours it says w out
correct
it's 10 21. in the in the 10 21 row
what does it say in the fourth column
well
for me that's walkout and you recall who
walked out of that meeting i have tried
to and i don't because
each threatened and stood up
and i'm not positive
who finally did the walkout
and then
what does it say what is it indicating
on the row for 11 12
2015. couple sessions showed one and a
half hours and then on 1217 what does
that show
amber alone showed two and a quarter
hours based on this ledger you saw amber
and mr depp for four couple sessions
that's right
dr anderson i'm showing you it's been
marcus anderson three
397 no
ejection is that correct
they didn't list objections in their
exhibit list and then we actually
communicated this morning and they said
they weren't a joke
all right
do you know who on the team you you
talked with
i'm sorry
okay all right so no objection all right
that's okay 397 in evidence then
defense 397.
um
and i will let you
which is cc00172
i'll let you take a look at it
it's one page email
so let me know when you're finished
do you recognize this email chain yes
do you know who christian carino is yes
again
on the page where it says
laurel.anderson28
gmail.com that's your email address yes
the email of march 28 2015 from mr
corrino he wrote
laurel my closest friend amber on copy
wants to come see you alone first and
then with her husband johnny we'll leave
it
to you two to arrange a time love you
both
you see that email did you receive that
email from march 18 2015. i did
and you responded to mr carino's email
correct as you can see yes
what was your understanding as to why
amber heard wanted to meet with you
i took the face value that miss heard
wanted to have a consultation
and
if
this is not infrequent that i might get
an email like this so and when i hear
that someone may then later want to come
in with their husband or spouse
yes i think it has to do with
relationship issue
um
on september 9th 2015 you received an
email from mr carino is that right
yes apparently he was trying to set it
up
and mr carino was trying to set up a
meeting uh with you and amber and mr
depp is that right yes that's what i
assumed
and you responded to mr carino's email
um correct
i did
and then at the top you received an
email from
amber heard
yes
and she wrote hi laurel thank you so
much for responding
i really appreciate it i have to speak
to my husband when he's done working
today
and make sure he's good with that time i
think it sounds perfect
thank you so much again i'm really
looking forward to meeting you i read
that correctly
yes
and
you received that email from
amber heard
i did
um on september 27 2015
you received an email from amber heard
correct
yes
and amber wrote hi laurel johnny and i
are back in town and would love to know
if you have any availability to see us
this week
please let me know thanks
you received that email from amber heard
yes
and you responded that you were
available on thursday at 5 30 p.m
correct yes
and and um
looking at the top of the email where it
says wednesday september 30th
um
would you agree that the next day is
uh thursday october 1st 2015. yes
and
we need to we can go back to your
billing ledger but the first time you
saw amber heard and mr def was on
october 1st 2015 is that right yes did
you see amber heard on december 17 2015
[Music]
yes
we
we had established that yes
all right
dr anderson i'm showing you it's been
marked as anderson exhibit seven
which is depth 3202
take a chance to read it and let me know
when you're finished
oh
yes
um attachment 7
is in
at the bottom is a you see a march 8
2016 email from christian carino to you
correct yes
and christian carino was asking if you
would be willing to make a house call to
johnny depp's apartment downtown is that
right
i did not know where he lived
his email says would you be willing to
make a house called johnny's apartment
downtown
did it say downtown
yes it did okay
and then you responded on march 8 2016.
correct
yes
and you wrote
hey christian have of course avoided
this my whole career unless someone was
in rehab would be willing to try it once
and that there's something i'd like
johnny to understand and i don't think
he does
um
where you wrote i'd like johnny to
understand
um
that i'd
where you wrote would
would be willing to try it once and that
there's something i'd like china to
understand that i don't think he does
what did you mean by that
i can't say exactly what it was i wanted
to in park but i i know that
i thought that he was
um
having difficulty in the sessions
and
i think it was something about the
process between the two of them that i
was trying to clue him into
what difficulty was mr depp having in
the sessions
having a voice
what do you mean by that
ms heard had a
jackhammer style of talking she was very
amped up he had trouble
talking at a similar pace
their dialogue
he was cut off a lot
i i i'm guessing this is
what i was
i'm not sure what i it is but there was
something anyhow this is how he didn't
have the rules he couldn't keep up with
her rapid fire
um way of conversation
and so he was
really overwhelmed
in in working with um
amber and mr depp
did amber
ever report to you any
physical violence on behalf of mr depp
toward amber
yes
what type of physical violence did she
report to you
do you recall seeing photos from amber
heard i i have but i don't remember when
i saw them
what do you recall about the photos
her face was bruised do you recall what
where on her face you saw on amber's
face you saw purses i think they were
around her eyes but i couldn't be
positive
did did you witness abuse by either
i didn't miss i didn't witness
have you worked with mr depp before
working with amber and mr dab
is it your testimony that
while mr depp may have said he wasn't
violent with
any of his other partners
there was violence between from mr depp
toward amber correct
yes you're right
he had he had had been well controlled i
think for almost i don't know
20 30 years
and
both were victims of
roots in their homes but i thought he
had been well controlled for decades
and then with
ms heard he was triggered and
um they
engaged in what i saw as mutual abuse
sometimes i'm not i know she led on more
than one occasion and started it to keep
him with her
because abandonment and having him leave
was her worst nightmare and i think he
may have initiated it on occasions too
and that i'm less sure
and how did you come to the
understanding that
on some occasions miss heard
physically abused mr doubt
miss heard reported that what did miss
heard report to you
that it was a point of pride two things
it was a point of pride to her if she
felt disrespected
to
initiate a fight
and was her father had beaten her she
was not going to and the second uh
the second one is what she reported to
me
which is if he was going to leave her to
de-escalate from the fight she would
strike him to keep him there she would
rather be in a fight than have him leave
did you speak to any other doctors or
psychologists that worked
with either amber or mr depp
no
did you review any
uh medical documents of mr depp or amber
i reviewed a
um
pharmacokinetic um
that that ms heard showed me
which has to do with
neurotransmitter function genetics and
medications
just to go back
doctor what
professional degrees do you hold
i have a
i have a couple of masters a phd in a
certified clinical nutrition
certification
would you mind please just um
elaborating on that for the record
yes i have a master's from young in my
early in my life in
teaching and curriculum i have a
master's in psych i have a phd in
clinical psychology i have a ccn which
is a certified clinical nutrition
um
certification
and do you recall dr uh in what year you
obtained your phd yes i got it in 82.
and if very briefly if you could just
please in summary fashion
just describe your employment history
from 1982 forward
after earning your phd
um i collected clinical hours
in hospitals and in psychiatric medical
groups i was employed to do some
nutrition
evaluation and intervention as well but
there were mds behind me we worked in
concert
then worked in a hospital with
i think i think that doctor was re uh
was
workers comp um and then when i was
you know i have it out of order
then i was on my own but i was employed
by that this is when i was employed by a
psychiatric medical group
um to do kind of a combination of
psychotherapy and some nutrition and
then since then i have been
a solo practitioner out of network word
of mouth only very small footprint
purposely
all of these years
when did you become a solo practitioner
um
very soon probably
uh in
probably in 86.
so is it fair to say that as of 2015 you
were you were already quite established
as a solo practitioner
yes
generally speaking what type of services
did you provide your patients in 2015
adults only
individual or couples work
and
with a limited number of people
there would have been neurotransmitter
testing and
some attention to
lifestyle and how
uh
nutritional elements affect the brain
and if you would just please describe
for us lay people what a clinical
psychologist does
um
the first thing is evaluation intake
gather material the second thing and the
way i work is kind of during the intake
process could be one session could be
four sessions depends on if it's an
individual or a couple i'm
conceptualizing i'm looking for
the process the content is something i
make notes on i care about it leads me
from session to session but i'm really
looking at process what's going on
between two people or what's actually
going on inside of someone the third
step is
i'm
i show my hand i talk about it i try to
get either three people in the room all
on the same page with me
or
one other person this is what i see and
then the onus is on me
to not just be a good friend and hold
someone's hand and talk about mom
but to
actually make change and so i lay out
here are the things i think we need to
work on
and then there are action steps for all
of them
so that someone has a more directed
sense of what they're doing in
psychotherapy as opposed to just coming
in and talking about how they feel
is it your practice when you have a
session with a couple that you take
notes from the session i absolutely take
notes from any section
do you take
at what time in relation to this session
do you take the notes
um i'm taking them during the session
and they know it
because i don't want hours and hours and
hours of homework at the end of a
clinical day so the notes are often
uh
you know a lot of typos wrong pronouns
here and there but essentially i'm just
trying to gather
facts as i go
is it fair to say that you take the
notes in a somewhat contemporaneous
fashion
sure
and you take those notes in the ordinary
course of your practice in your business
absolutely
do you maintain or do you keep those
notes
as part of your uh treatment and regular
course ordinary course of business i do
thank you
and what type of information generally
do you keep in your notes other than
what you've already testified about
whatever i want to
anything that
com
it could be content that i'm tracking
just so i know in the next session what
kind of content
we were talking about
um and it could be processed too
stand by and i'll mark that as a plans
exhibit number one
showing one on the screen just to
confirm have you seen this uh document
before dr anderson yes
and and what is it
it's a christian carino doing the first
contact and the second one is from miss
hurd
wanting to know how to get in touch with
me but accepting
what's been thrust upon us when was your
first couples therapy involving this
hurt october 1st 2015.
was that an in-person session yes
where was the session held in my office
and and mr depp was also there correct
yes
how long was that first session
three and a half hours
was that the first time that you had
ever met miss heard in person
i think so
and was that the first time you had ever
met
mr depp in person
yes
okay now if if you could please turn and
this is a multi-page exhibit uh mr natal
half did not show you
uh this is going to be plaintiff's
exhibit two
standby
did i interrupt a second ben sure um
adam can you turn up your microphone
because everyone's a lot louder than you
and when you object i struggle to hear
you
can you hear me
well
michelle is a lot louder than you so if
you talk at the same time
i can't hear you
all right i'll see what i can yeah i'll
see what i can do thank you
and dr anderson if you could just take
as long as you would like to familiarize
yourself with this document i'll just
state for the record these are
documents that you produced
that have a bates designation
1 through
17.
yes i'm familiar
um what are these oh well strike that
have you ever seen
plaintiff's exhibit 2 before
yes
what what is it it's a redacted copy of
my personal notes that i provided to you
guys
and are these um i think you testified
in response to mr nadel house
questioning
that the names and henry and joey davis
are pseudonyms
yes
and would you please just identify for
us who and henry is in real life and
henry is amber heard joey davis is
johnny depp
and are these uh your notes that you
took contemporaneously
of the
four couples
of strike that
are these your contemporaneous notes
that you took of the couple's therapy
sessions
yes
would these notes include
any session that you had
for
misheard that was not part of the
couple's therapy
no
did you have any
sessions with mr depp
individually that weren't part of the
couple's therapy
no during this period of time
it's color-coded black is couples red is
ms heard and blue is mr depp
uh whether i talk to them or saw them
individually or as a couple it was all
in service of couples therapy
understood and so these notes in
plaintiff's exhibit two
and
encompass
all of the couples therapies sessions
that you had
with mr depp and miss heard
either
when they appeared together
or when they appeared separately in the
context of your couple's therapy is that
correct
i'm looking at one page if you're
talking about the entire redacted
document yes
and i've asked you the question
generally but i want to ask you in the
context of of these 17 pages
did you prepare these 17 pages
of couples therapy
notes
in the ordinary course of your treatment
of mr depp and miss heard
yes
did you
maintain or keep them in the ordinary
course of your practice or business i
did so my question was
uh what is the significance of october 1
2015
um i'm going to look at what i'm reading
so that this makes sense to you this
can't possibly make sense but it makes
sense to me okay
they reported what they said to one
another
so the first line is ms heard talking
saying that mr depp says to her no one
likes you you're getting fame from me
i'm falling out of love with you you're
a [ __ ] she's reporting just in the
first session
just how bad the relationship is just
how mean they are to one another
and at that point i because i'm
typing quickly as they go along i'm
switching into a different voice
more about the process between them
where
she has i believe
interrupted him he says no more about
what she says
about him
and
it's just that they're fighting and she
has a hard time
she bites the bait she can't let him
talk
is is my recollection and from this
that's kind of what that is so it gives
me a sense of
what they're doing at home they're each
reporting this is what we say to each
other
okay i appreciate that dr anderson i'm
just going to try to break it down into
a little bit um so october 1 2015 is the
date of the first couple session correct
yes
and two and a half means two and a half
hours long from start to finish
i am guessing they were in they were
present for two and a half hours but
that i waited whatever the first doc the
ledger says but i waited an hour for
them to show up and dr anderson
in that first bullet point that we can
see
you right jay says no one likes you
getting fame from me
falling out of love with you [ __ ] jay
is johnny depp
yes but that was said by ms heard
so m is it fair to say that ms heard was
saying
that johnny
said to her no one likes you you're
getting fame from me
i'm falling out of love with you [ __ ]
that that would that would have come
from mr depp is that correct
ms heard reported that that's what mr
depp said to her at their worst yeah did
amber when he when
mr depp told you that amber had hit him
in the jaw
did amber respond in any way did she
deny it did she admit it uh i don't
think she denied it
but what i believe from my notes
was that
they galloped she galloped off in a new
direction and they
continued to talk and there was no more
that johnny depp was going to say about
what he was reporting it was more that
they started into a fight and i
wrote that their process
is a back and forth firing at each other
at that
point he had some energy
and they don't communicate they have
terrible skills
at any point during the first session
did miss heard
interrupt mr depp when he was trying to
talk yes
she talked over him she had rapid fire
talking
did she interrupt him during your other
sessions
that are reflected in plaintiff's
exhibit two
yes and i pointed out the process to her
at some point and she got it
that
she that no one could actually have a
decent dialogue with her if she was
rapid firing and talking over and just
barraging it was a process issue
you write doesn't answer directly when
he asks her a question
to what were you referring there
don't have a clue if i could direct your
attention further down the page from
plan
you see the notation to october 6 2015
yes
was that the second couple session no
it's red it's amber alone so is it fair
to say that you met alone with with
amber for two and a third hours in the
context of the couple's therapy is that
correct
yes this was to get her background
material
so tell us what you mean
in that one section
he hits her no closed fist she hits back
and now starts it for pride because
father
hit her would you please tell us
what you meant by that
this is her reporting to me
uh it's the only thing in this
uh
clinical session that apparently was
about physical abuse or else it would uh
not have been redacted out
um it's so when she said in terms of
physical abuse
that he hits her
a no close fist means an open hand slap
to me
and she says that she hits back and now
she starts it and sometimes hits him
first
because her history is having been
violated by her father physically
and just out of pride
she
uh
if she's
a lot of things trigger her and if she's
triggered she would hit him first
and the he you're referring to is johnny
depp correct yes
when you said that she
sometimes hits johnny first
because of pride what did you mean she
was sensitive to feeling
disrespected
um and a number of other things but
and so
and if she felt disrespected
she had
come out of her background history
um feeling that her pride needed to be
needed to dominate and she needed to
stand up for herself when miss heard
told you that johnny depp hits her or
slaps her
johnny depp was not present correct
correct
and
and it wasn't plural
it was she referred to
well i wrote he hits her
yes
so maybe it was plural
but he was not present when she made
that assertion he was not
did
miss hurt tell you
that
she sucked mr deb
yes
um
she was describing kind of the
progression of the physical violence
did you have any understanding of what
she meant
when she admitted that she sucks mr depp
yes because
there were three lines above this
that explained the progression a bit
and i've already said what it was
she felt she had to hit him back if he
hit her
and so she always did
and
and again that entry is from
a session where mr depp was not
physically present correct that's right
okay let's move to the next session
uh october 7
2015
and this is a three and a half hour
session is that correct
yes
was that an in-person session yes
did both mr depp and miss heard
attend
no this is blue this is john mr depp's
intake
understood
and let's move now um to the toward the
bottom of the page and i think i'm
finally getting the code right
um
so the next session occurred on october
14 2015
and it was the two of them for three
hours is that correct yes
and that was another in-person session
true
yes
um and am i right to say
that every single
piece of your notes as to the
october 14 2015 session has been
redacted is that true
yes but to clarify something earlier on
the ledger
yes i wrote two hours couple then amber
it means he is the one who walked out of
that session my question was um am i
correct
that all of your notes
for the october 14 2015
couple session for three hours are
completely redacted is that true yes
so um
so the next session occurred on october
21 2015 true sure
and it lasted two hours it started as a
couple
then mr depp left and then you spoke
only with amber but in the context of
couples therapy is that right yeah okay
and let's go to the next session on
uh page 10.
the next session
was on october 24 2015
and i can't see from the code was that
a couple's therapy or was it just one or
the other of them attending i don't know
this is a red phone session with ms
heard
okay great
um and it lasted one and a half hours
yes
so the next session was after that was
on
october 29th 2015 is that right
yes and that just
that one no that one was uh canceled oh
it was canceled that's why it's so short
okay and then the one after that still
on page 10
was
on
november 12 2015.
there's a an appointment on 11 4 that
was canceled that i didn't put an entry
on
okay well thank you that's helpful uh
what about uh november 12th was that a
joint session yes it was
and was that in person
yes okay and then the next
session on page 11
is uh that even i can understand uh so
there was a no show on december 4th 2015
is that right
yes i i'd like to clarify the no-shows
please please do
um
i think they both told me but i think mr
depp told me at one point but i already
knew because this happens with couples
when a couple is having a lot of trouble
in sessions
but they're doing well at home and
they're in a little bit of a honeymoon
you know period
they cancel instead of coming in because
they know coming in will get them into
conflict
okay and and
fair to say that that happened again on
december
uh
10th 2015.
i can't tell which sessions they were
sick or wish which tesh which sessions
they were cancelling because of this
dynamic but it was admitted and
explained to me and i understood it
fully
okay
um and still on page 11
the next session
was on december 15 2015 and it was a
telephonic session is that right
with
yes with uh ms heard
that was with misheard okay
you write then last night monday she
slapped him as he sat there talking
incoherently
who slapped who
i actually i actually know what happened
what happened this was as i said ms
heard talking on the phone to me
mr depp's mother was an icu
he had been
doing a lot of he was [ __ ] up as she
would say on a lot of drugs
and
she slapped him because he was being
incoherent and talking about another
being with another woman
did she
did she tell you that he had hit her
first or was she the one who initiated
the slap she initiated that one because
i think she felt demeaned and threatened
and
this is what she reported to you correct
yes
he was not present
he was not on the call
when she made these allegations uh
was was was he no
and you didn't see any of this did you
no
and you didn't see her in person
okay um
then
there is a
notation
uh
should she call police question mark
where is that
that's um
right below
what we were just talking about in red
it says
should she call police what does that
refer to so what did you mean
that was her asking me did you respond
to her
i believe i did then you write doesn't
want to divorce
wants to want to divorce
yes what did you mean by that
she loved him
he loved her
she believed that she wasn't stupid she
knew that what they were doing wasn't
healthy and so she wanted to want to
divorce him but she didn't
and yet
it had escalated to this point so she
was
trying to figure out what to do and she
had an entourage around her telling her
what to do
who was her entourage
uh she had a routine group of friends
that stayed with her lived in her home
probably as well as uh paid people that
i don't know
do you recall the names of any of her
entourage
one was rocky
directing your attention to the last
snippet from that session
will she have advantage if she leaves
him
but files with police for abuse first
was that a question that she asked you
yes this was her talking out loud trying
to strategize for herself
so i'm plants exhibit three on the
screen
and dr anderson i think this is the same
document
that mr nadel half showed you
as anderson exhibit six so i'm not going
to ask you to identify
it again but i do have a couple of um
questions about it that mr nadelhof did
not ask i believe you testified and
correct me if i'm wrong that you have
never spoken to any of miss herds other
psychologists or therapists is that true
that's true
and putting that aside
when she refers to her own therapist in
this exhibit three
do you know the name of that person
putting aside whether you have ever
spoken to him or her
i do not
okay
did miss hurt ever explain to you
why the nuances and
complexity of her relationship with mr
depp
would be lost on her
own therapist i believe that she felt
known in a
more thorough way in terms of her her
behavior inside of the relationship
and let's pick up where we left off on
the bottom of page 11
of plaintiff's exhibit two
okay and specifically the entry that
begins
on january 13 it's at the very bottom of
page 11 so literally the last line oh
that's it
on this on
january 13 2016
was
this a uh joint session with mr depp and
miss heard or was this just with one of
them
it was only misheard
and let me go back and see if it was
phone no no no i'm sorry it was in
person no
no no no never mind 113 16.
was
misheard
in person
and do you know how long this in-person
session was was misheard on january 13
2016. i think it was probably just one
hour
okay
you right didn't fight on island till
last day
on island started to get into something
uh what did you what were you referring
to there
well christmas had occurred
and the goal was
they had a lot of people go into his
island and they were going to be
together and the goal was to try and get
through the christmas holiday without
fighting
and so she was reporting on that
then
uh you write he got aggressive
threatening didn't touch him
hidden bathroom
what were you referring to there
what she reported to me
um
which was
an improvement that she didn't
participate
so she is it fair to say that she told
you she did not hit him at that time
yes that's what i believe my notes say
yes
then you write she threw can it him
since home fighting then she better
who is this she who threw a can at him
misheard
and the him
whom she threw a can at was mr depp
correct yes
did you receive that email on or about
march 8th in the morning at 6 23 a.m
well apparently because i responded in
the morning
okay well then let's we'll skip it we'll
go right back to your response
um
so
the response at the top of the page of
the second entry i suppose
did you write that email
to mr carino on march 8 2016 at 7 27 a.m
i did
and
fair to say that you weren't
enthusiastic about the idea of making a
house call
i was not
and
mr nadel paft asked you about
what it was you wanted
johnny to understand about the process
and i i was wrong because i can see now
the date of it looking at it more
carefully this is after
the relationship has evolved
considerably so what i
i think was guessing
was earlier in the
relationship i don't know what it was i
wanted him to understand let's go back
to exhibit two then
please and we're not going to repeat
we're just picking up where we left off
and now we've gotten up to page 13 of
the 17 page of your notes
now if we can start out exactly
um do you see where the notes of your
session on june
18th 2016 begin
yesterday
and was this a
solo session couples session between you
and mr depp only
this is with mr jeff it's blue it's just
the two of us
gotcha
and it lasted
one and a third hours
yeah
you write fight on her
april 22nd
birthday
he late
huge fight his mother died on the 20th i
think i know what you're referring to
but if you could please describe that
for the record
one second
this is when i got the scaramanja
productions on my phone
so he found me at home which was new
um
domestic violence charges had already
been made
his mother had just died on the 20th
well when
he told you that there was a fight
on
april 22 first 22 birthday was that ms
hurt's 30th birthday
i think it was
and is he telling you
that he arrived late for
the birthday dinner party and there was
a huge fight yes
do you know who tacia von rie is
yeah well i know her name i know she was
someone that ms heard was in a
relationship with
then you write was chaotic
violence but gave as good as she got
what does that mean i believe i'm
quoting
i'm i think i'm quoting what some of
this is just my typing the words he's
using while he's talking very ver he's
also very verbal when no one's
interrupting him um
and i think he talked about how chaotic
it was how violent it was and she gave
as good as she got that's kind of a
direct quote those are not my that's not
my language directing your attention
further down the page
to the entry
for july 13 2016
three hours amber in person was that an
in-person meeting you had a couple's
theory therapy with only misheard
no this is not couples therapy this is
miss miz heard by herself i wrote in
person
okay um
so just to be clear
what follows in your these are your
notes
for your individual
treatment of ms heard having nothing to
do with couples therapy not true
in my mind uh the dust had not settled
on the couple yet
and
this was just kind of aftermath of the
the uh
kind of falling apart of the marriage
but
i didn't mean to mischaracterize
anything i was just trying to obsess out
what it was no this is not individual
therapy for her this is about the
marriage if we could please go to
exhibit six solution which is a new
document when i say new um it was
produced
by dr anderson's office but knew in the
sense that
mr natalhop didn't ask her about it
dr anderson have you ever seen this
document before of course i created it
okay
and what is it
it's a treatment summary when i was
first uh
subpoenaed
or my notes were required years ago
my notes are jumbly they don't say a lot
they're they're confusing they're you
know
as you've seen or you haven't seen
actually
so
um i did what psychologists do you take
you go through all of those notes
and you
and your brain because it's not as if
you're not left with a
very you know i hope a very clear sense
of what went on so i took everything i
thought and believed conceptually about
them i went through all of my notes and
i wrote this treatment summary
and then if you could go up paragraph is
still there yeah and i want to ask you
about that one paragraph
i think you've described this in the
course of your testimony but i did want
to ask you
about your sentence
she reported oh
always hitting him back as a point of
pride
but admitted that she eventually
initiated the hitting herself
is this she you're referring to miss
heard
it is
and is the hymn you're referring to
johnny depp
it is okay let's move to the next page
please
and i just want to focus on the one a
snippet on bates
page three
sorry
you write she reported trying to
initiate a fight with him one night by
slapping him when she was offended by
what he said
is this she you're referring to there
miss heard
yes it is
and is the he you're referring to johnny
depp yes it is then in the last sentence
it was also at this time
that she showed me photos of her
injuries
when did miss hurt show you photos of
her alleged injuries
well to the best of my pulling together
the information i wrote down
i'm
i'm saying it was right after that fight
and she my recollection as she came in
she talked to me by phone and then came
in the next day
or at least i thought i thought that
somewhere around the time she got the
injury i know she came in in person to
show me
did she show you photos or did she show
you
you said she showed you photos and so
it your testimony that she showed you
photos
of her
injuries
shortly after the alleged event
somewhere in the period while she still
had
injuries she showed me photos but she
also came in and showed me in person
and what did she show you in person
bruising on her face
other than the bruising on her face what
else what other injuries did she show
you i don't remember there may have been
more but i don't remember
and
you weren't present during the alleged
physical
injuries correct
correct
so the only basis you had
with respect
to the cause of the injuries was what
ms heard told you correct
yes
and you write
the physical violence that occurred
between them appeared to me to be mutual
you never actually
witnessed any physical violence by mr
depp or by misheard correct never
and you said that they were each victims
of domestic violence both in their
family
they were each victims of domestic
violence in their families what did you
mean by that
they were each
beaten
by parents
go back very briefly to exhibit 2.
page 11.
and um
after the part where
this this refers to a session that was
just uh
you and miss heard right yes
and this call which was just between you
and miss miss heard and not mr depp
involved
that occurred
on or about december 15 2015.
yes
and
was it just shortly after that call
about when miss heard
showed you pictures and actually came
into your office is that right she came
in on 12 17 so yes so so miss herd came
in on december 17th
and you saw bruises on her face is that
correct
i believe that's when
was that bruising that you observed
similar to the bruising
that appeared on the photographs that
she showed you
yes
you testified that what you saw in
person was similar to what
you saw in the photographs amber gave
you correct yes
when
she came into your office on december
17th
what did her face look like
what i recall is not purple green and
blue but just a darkening so kind of a
dark
a darker gray blue sort of thing
but
i i i don't have a photo of it i don't
remember that well
is that dr anderson consistent with your
understanding that there were no other
entries
on december 15 uh or december 17th
relating to physical abuse
you know um
there was nothing about physical abuse
nothing in that next session it was all
about christmas and get in her therapist
telling her one thing
what was the size of the bruise on her
face that you observed on december 17th
maybe like this
in more than one place
you said it wasn't
so is it fair to say those are small
bruises in more than one place
so there was how many one inch size
bruises were on her face that you
observed i'm not a good person to ask
this question to i don't really remember
i wasn't looking to memorize it i think
there's other data that will support
this not from me
a few minutes ago you briefly spoke
about
seeing bruises about it about an inch on
on amber hurst's face you recall that
testimony
yes
and
you were you were making motions with
your fingers but i was saying multiple
i'm not saying one right you were seeing
multiple multiple bruises on amber's
face
when you um
were talking about how the size of it
you your fingers were under your eyes
did you you remember seeing the bruises
under amber's eyes that's what i recall
they may have been in other places
throughout her body i don't remember
but i i do remember her face
you could turn to page 13.
um
in the blue
where it says
was chaotic
violent
do you know what mr depp was referring
to there
what i said previously and i'll say it
again
um he's kind of doing a retrospective of
trying to understand the relationship
um
and is characterizing it
as chaotic and violent but she gave as
good as she got and he
uh and she's she started it but and you
know he's he's complaining but he's also
just kind of describing what the
relationship was his
um mother is dead at this point the
relationship is
not
is not good it's over pretty much and
he's trying to come to terms
with it and he still loves her
and his mourning so he's just
he's a very articulate man and when left
alone to speak he can describe
intelligently what's going on i think
i'm kind of
i think while he's talking and i'm not
trying to be obtrusive with my
taking notes
i'm listening i'm talking but i'm also
copying down a word here and there so my
belief is that those are his words
and and mr depp i think you testified
about this but i just want to make sure
clear mr depp told you
amber gave as good as she got correct
correct
did you ask what mr dutt meant by gave
as good as she got
um i was pretty aware of what he meant i
agreed what did what did you understand
mr deaf to me all right i have um
she initiated fights she started
violence she
uh rose to the challenge if he started
first which i
and so she
in my opinion that had been established
throughout the relationship
that she fought as hard as he did and he
tried to de-escalate far more than i
think she did do you know did mr depp
talk about his fingertip with you before
june 18 2016.
no because i would have written it when
he first mentioned it to me
did you ever see mr depp with an injury
to his finger during any of your
sessions with mr death or
counseling or
you know sessions together with amber
herr during that session yes he showed
me
on june 18th 2016 but before june 18
2016 did you ever see an injury to mr
dev's finger no
but in yes no i didn't
when we were
going through amber's
the incidents where amber described mr
depp being violent mr depp was not
present correct that's true
all right thank you all right ladies and
gentlemen we'll go ahead and take our
lunch for the afternoon now no outside
research not talk to anybody and we'll
give you until 2 15 okay so you can be
excused with wluson now thank you
all right
for this afternoon do you need this tv
anymore for this afternoon
for the first witness
or
the last witness so we can put it down
during lunch
okay perfect all right we'll be back at
2 15 and thank you
the one we have in the binder
it looks different than the one you had
on the screen so i'm not sure
the one on the screen looked much more
redacted but maybe this is redacted
okay so the emails are all right
everything
[Music]
i think
i just want to make sure because i
seemed like the one on the screen had a
little more redaction than the one i'm
seeing here so i just
i didn't think it did
well there are identifiers on here at
least emails there's no cell phones on
here those have been redacted i didn't
think the emails were redacted
i thought they were the same but okay
no i don't i don't care i just want to
make sure everybody's agrees that the
one that i have is the one that's in
evidence
i think you're on the one that was on
the screen did in fact redact the email
addresses also which is not the same as
i think that you have so we can i think
we can replace it probably
did you reduce that we didn't um david
murphy redacted it
okay i apologize
i apologize um so yeah we will provide
you the red we'll provide you the
regulation so i need to redact it there
is there any chance in the future that
you could guys maybe can talk ahead of
time and get this these redacted ahead
of head ahead of time or something
possibly
okay
all right it's just i already i still
have three pending redaction now
oh look with a smile on your face mr
rottenborn i see that he's trying to
make you happy yeah i know
he wants to be the star of the day
that's okay
all right so now i have 844 the redacted
copy correct
and i have 210
the redacted copy
okay
perfect
all right
so that then just leaves me with
397 then
correct
548 also okay 548 and 397 now
okay perfect all right anything else
this time
oh good okay ready for the cherry
so
okay
[Music]
all right
your next witness mr two
uh
all right excuse that again i'm sorry
okay can you spell that last name before
me d-e-u-t-e-r-s
thank you
truthfully in this case
all right
all right thank you
all right
and good afternoon miss duders
hi
would you please state your full name
for the record yes it's um georgina
diane deuters but i i go by gina okay
and uh miss deuters where are you from
london
and can you tell us a little bit about
what your occupation is
um i currently am a freelance creator
who
kind of conceptualizes and shoots
and edits um photographs and clips
largely for social media
and how long have you been doing that oh
just a few years
before that i was a visual effects
coordinator for
movies
and can you tell us just very briefly
what that means um it's it's
basically the managing of cg and effects
in
films the delivery of and
um yeah just
the managing of that yeah and how long
did you do that
oh um from 2002 to 2016. okay
any films we might recognize
um
charlie and the chocolate factory
um the dark knight
um
terrible christmas movie that i won't
mention um
uh pirates of the caribbean
for
yeah
do you know johnny depp i do
and how do you know johnny depp
he is a good friend of mine
when did you first meet mr depp
i met him um
summer of 2005. um
it was actually at the charlie and the
chocolate factory premiere my husband
stephen introduced me to him um
at
a dinner after the premiere and uh
yeah he was
super
sweet and warm and kind of ushered us in
to join him at dinner and
i remember being very nervous like i am
now um
and yeah that's when we first met
okay
uh you say your husband stephen
introduced you to mr deputy yeah how did
your husband know it
i'm sorry
how did your husband stephen know mr
dapp oh he started working with him on
charlie and the chocolate factory um he
started off in production
but then um joined the depth department
um during the shoot
and does he still work for mr depp yeah
and in what capacity
um well he started off as like personal
assistants and it's kind of
developed into produce a writer type
role with johnny's guidance
so for how long has he worked for mr
depp then
18 years i think i think since 2004.
now over those 18 years um
where has he been working
um
all over the place um
it depends on whether film is is being
shot so um
the bahamas hawaii
london l.a
kind of all over
and have you where have you been during
this time
well um
stephen and i our first two films were
we worked on the same film but then he
went off to do pirates and i went off to
do other films so
i wouldn't always be with them um
i know that in between my projects um
you know johnny was always mindful that
me and steven didn't spend too much time
apart so he would
usually be you know kind enough to um
fly me out uh to be with them wherever
they were
okay
about how many times would that happen
in a given year if you can estimate for
us
two to three
yeah and it'd be like you know sometimes
i'd be with them for like a month
sometimes just a couple of weeks
okay
uh can you just generally describe for
us very briefly um
your husband's relationship with mr deb
um
[Music]
it's a great one
it's um
they are
very close professionally and um
personally um i know that stephen
um really respects johnny looks up to
him
and johnny's been a mentor to him um and
has really encouraged steven's career um
develop
[Music]
and great friends too
and can you just very briefly and very
generally tell us what it was like on
those time periods when you were
spending time uh chunks of time with mr
depp and your uh husband well if
okay what was the question sorry
just generally described for us okay so
so if they were if they were working it
would be
you know like on wrap we'd kind of have
dinner together
um
and then i'd kind of entertain myself
while the boys went off to work
if it was during downtime you know he it
would um
probably be like a family holiday so it
would include his long-term partner
vanessa and their little kids
um which was always really lovely um
really happy memories there
so it kind of depended
okay
uh
how well would you say you know mr dutt
very well okay
over the course of your friendship with
mr depp and i apologize did you say it
had been 17 years
i'm not great at maths but 2005 to now i
think is
17.
over the course of your friendship with
mr depp have you ever seen mr depp take
drugs
yes
and which ones
i've seen him smoke weed and um
occasionally cocaine
okay have you ever seen him drink yes
all right have you ever partaken of any
of these substances at the same time yes
okay
about how many times would you estimate
you've seen
mr depp use cocaine
oh gosh um
i mean it's usually
like
you know kind of a celebratory event
like after a gig or a
party or
something 20 i don't know
um
20 times over the
i don't know yeah i
about 20 times about yeah and that's
over
i mean yeah i haven't been kind of
keeping count but
it's not a it's not
it's not a regular thing
sporadic it's
okay and that's 20 times over what
period of time
gosh
i think like the last maybe 10 years
and uh how often have you seen mr depp
consume alcohol
um since i've met him
okay
um
can you describe for us um
how mr depp seems to respond to cocaine
um
i quite honestly
can't gauge much
difference in his demeanor
you know
this stuff kind of tends to make the
average person a bit chattier and maybe
stays up a bit longer than they should
uh
but
um nothing out of the
ordinary okay
same question for alcohol how would you
say based on your interactions with him
while he's drinking how does he seem to
uh respond to it
um
it's kind of annoying but he doesn't he
holds his liquor very well um
so uh
gosh
kind of
um
more jovial or just
i've never seen him i've honestly never
seen him like
drunk drunk
i've never been with him
in that kind of situation
does he seem to drink to excess in your
experience
no
okay
have you ever seen him get angry or
violent well on cocaine no definitely
not
have you ever seen him get angry or
violent well on alcohol no
ms duders
do you know amber laura heard
yes
and
when did you first meet ms hurd
when did when did i yes
um well we met
kind of very briefly on the set of the
run diary but you know it's just kind of
quick
greeting in the craft tent i think
and just so everybody's on the same page
um what is the run diary
the rum diary is a movie that
we shot in
2009
in puerto rico
um
and
yeah it started johnny and amber
and i was i was i was there with stephen
that was one of the times that i wasn't
working so i traveled out to be with
stephen and i was i was around i did end
up
doing a little thing for the visual
effects department but
mostly it was leisure for me
was there anything noteworthy about your
interactions with misheard on that
occasion
no
okay
when did you next meet ms hurd
on i think a couple of years later um
one diary press tour i went to the
premiere in london
and again it was just a
kind of um
you know
greeting it wasn't we didn't kind of
hang out chat probably or anything
and again just so just so everybody's on
the same page what is a press tour
a press tour is when um
when a film comes out the actors and the
director usually travel around with
um the film and show it in different
cities all over the world and the actors
usually have to
do interviews to promote it and just get
the word out
okay
and this was a press tour for run diary
yeah and what city were you in
i
i went to the london one
okay
anders
does anything stand out to you about
your interactions with miss herd on that
occasion
no she no
okay
were you aware at that point that mr
depp and ms heard had started a
relationship yes and how are you aware
because um
depp's
team johnny's team sorry
johnny's team um
there's just always an open
constant flow of information
um
you know
because ultimately
you know jerry judge
would be looking after
johnny so would kind of
get updates as to where they were going
and what he was doing and so in that way
we got
kind of you know notification
notified that
you know they just got together
okay and you mentioned a name there
jerry judge can you just tell the jury
who that is
um okay i don't wanna be upset but jerry
judge was johnny's
long-term security um
uh guy and he
yeah i was a really
a dear
individual um we all loved him very much
and he was he was like family
he was like
a dad um
and unfortunately he passed away
okay
when did you next see ms heard after the
press tour in london
okay so that's
that's like 2011.
um
[Music]
i think it was on a
trip that we accompanied
johnny and amber on
to las vegas for a few days
and can you estimate for us
just approximately when that was
oh maybe that's 2012. i'm so sorry like
um
um
i i
i
i'm banking on the on the date um but it
it would have been after they'd you know
started seeing each other maybe a couple
months afterwards um and we just went
out there for a few days i don't i don't
remember if it was just like a little
excursion for them um or if johnny had
something to do there i don't remember
that
it was just for like
two three days
anything stand out to you about that
trip
um
i was kind of excited to meet amber
you know because she was
johnny's new
girl and um
i remember
kind of trying to
you know kind of make eye contact and
um
yes um
i kind of felt a bit ignored which is
fine you know
with staff or whatever
so
i didn't i didn't really chat with her
when you say staff
well i mean i'm i'm not employed by
johnny but you know i'm obviously
stephen's wife and he's staff and
um yeah i
didn't really interact with her
okay um so can you kind of describe what
happened when you saw her then if
anything
um
no no nothing nothing of note just um
that she didn't really engage or
um
make
you know i yeah just
didn't really acknowledge
our presence
did you see uh mr depp and ms hurd
interact at all yeah on that trip yeah
okay and can you describe that for us
they seemed pretty in love um
they were
tactile and um
you know they seemed
happy
okay
when did you next meet mister
um
when
johnny and stephen had gone out on
location to shoot the lone ranger so i
think that might have been
the next year
so bad with dates sorry
um
yeah so oh um so um
you know i think through
johnny and stephen
amber and i were
um kind of put in touch and we
went vintage shopping together and um
i went to get a coffee once
and and then with johnny and stephen
kind of
looked around some galleries um art
galleries
about how long would you say the period
was that you and this heard were
together in this time frame
how long were you both
out on location right yeah
i'm not sure about her and
i know that
i know that i personally made two trips
um
which seemed to coincide with her being
there so it you know it was nice um
and um
you know kind of meeting up to go
vintage shopping she was really really
lovely really sweet
we got on very well um
and it was fun it was
yeah
you know she's very charming
did you discuss her relationship with mr
daffodil
um
i remember like going for a coffee um
and
she seemed
a bit um
just a bit kind of frustrated that
i i don't think johnny was
ready to go public with their
relationship
[Music]
yet um
and um i think that was
you know
frustrating for her
did you form an impression that she
wanted to go public immediately
all right i'll sustain as to speculation
next question
were you out in public
yeah yeah yeah
yes
um
when you were interacting with miss
heard in this time frame did you notice
at all whether she was wearing makeup
no i don't think she was wearing makeup
um she's
naturally beautiful it's um i remember
you know
just thinking how
gorgeous her skin was and how yeah
pretty she was
and i mean how could you tell that she
wasn't wearing that well i um
consider myself
to be quite
the makeup
expert um you know earlier on in my
adult life i kind of got hormonal acne
which was awful so i got kind of
professional like covering that up um so
i think i'm pretty good at telling
if someone's wearing you know like
foundation or concealer
uh have you ever heard of arnica cream
yes in fact
um
i actually was using it the other week
um
you can you can use the microphone just
i just having trouble hearing you i'm
sorry oh there you go it's on there
the question was have you ever heard of
it and she answered it and then
continued past so it's
all right she's answered the question
she's answered the question all right if
you want to ask another question i'm
sure you're on this one uh what is it
it's a homeopathic
uh
lotion that you use to
help
bruises heal faster
and have you ever used it yourself
yes i was using it a couple weeks ago
because i had a
huge bruise on my hip after i had a
full
um yeah so
i know what it is
and can you just describe for those of
us who have no idea like myself um what
does arnica cream look like
um
oh sorry that was me um it's kind of
like a white emollient
cream um
opaque
that you rub into your skin um you rub
into the bruise
once it's been rubbed in
what does it look like transparent okay
and so is the brew is still visible oh
absolutely yeah
all right
us to leading
all right
all right after uh
after after that uh those interactions
with ms heard on the set of um
lone ranger and did you say 2013
which i'm not sure if that's an
objection but
i'll
i'll withdraw the date
after after your interactions uh with ms
heard on the set of the lone ranger uh
miss duders when did you next uh what do
you next recall seeing miss heard
i think it was on the press tour for the
lone ranger um
by that point i believe they their
relationship was public
and
we traveled to japan with
their kids johnny's kids
and her friend
britney
who i think was you know along with am's
friend but also to help
take care of the kids while
you know johnny was working and
okay
and why why were you traveling to japan
again
um because the lone ranger
was premiering there and
they were doing press and then we also
traveled like just
um berlin i think as well
and all around
were you traveling with mr depp and
mister yes
okay
did you witness any interactions between
mr deputy on these trips
um
i mean just generally on the plane um
nothing to note i'm
there was um
an incident like when we were all at
dinner together um
when i say we all i mean also the other
actors and
the producers and director
and i noticed that
johnny
was kind of hiding a drink on the side
of his chair and
taking secret sips
um and and and i just i i noticed you
know she kind of
saw that and was
quite angry about it and um
i couldn't hear what was said but he
seemed to get
kind of getting into got hold off by you
know the telling off
um
which was
it was kind of weird you know it's a bit
like um telling off a child
what was he drinking
i think it was
i think with champagne
okay like a flute of champagne yeah
something like that
um
did anything
do you have any impressions of
how would you describe their body
language when they were having this
conversation
um
um quite
um
you know i think she was
really angry so
um
um
just just kind of like dominant and and
um just very angry and you know putting
just
telling you know him off
okay and how would you describe his body
language
um i think you know quite
uh
just
exhausted by the whole
being told off like a child
okay
over this period of time and just to
clarify um
we're misheard and missed public at this
point
yes okay so it was it was yeah
well i mean
when we arrived at airports there was
like photographers everywhere so
and they i mean you know it wasn't a
very public guy yeah
okay
over this period of time then after
they'd gone public did you uh
ever witness them together um did you
have a perspective on their interactions
in general
objection relevance foundation
is
well their interactions are directly
relevant your honor uh i can lay more
foundation if the court laws you only
foundation that's fine uh did you ever
witness miss hurd and mr depp together
in this time period
um sorry could you repeat sorry i know
you said it a few times but could you
just repeat it one more time of course
um
over this next couple of years
after after the press tour for um
lone ranger
did you
have occasion to
interact with mr deb and miss hurt at
the same time did you see them together
um very rarely okay yeah i i'm
i'm thinking maybe a dinner here or
there
okay yeah
from those occasions when you did see
them
did you form any impressions about how
they were getting along
based on their interactions with each
other that you personally witnessed
i
still don't think it's
established the foundation it's been a
few few times that he saw a couple
dinners and she's asking for her
perspective on their relationship right
on those particular occasions what's the
relevance of her impressions
i'll rephrase okay
how would you describe their
interactions on those occasions when you
witnessed them
it's the same same thing aaron has still
no foundation
she is present
i'll allow it
um
i
they seemed okay i mean uh
some you know they could be quite tense
um
but
nothing nothing to note
nothing i would
remark on
were you invited to their wedding yeah
yes and did you attend yes
okay
can you just generally describe for us
what the wedding was like
it was definitely
a
predominantly
amber event
in the sense that
large percentage of the guests
were her friends and family
um
and
you know
a lot of his friends
and family couldn't make it because it
seemed to happen so quickly
um
uh
and
yeah they seem to be having oh her and
her friends seem to be having a
wonderful time
where did the wedding take place
on
um johnny's island in the bahamas
and did you have any interactions with
miss heard during this time period or
yes
did you did you talk to mr um when you
were at the wedding
yeah um you know there were dinners and
it was certainly
a celeb you know a celebration every day
um
you know
amber and her friend rocky
gave me my first
taste of mdma
you know
everyone was everyone knew like all her
friends were on it and so i tried that
for the first time with them um
yeah
it was like a party atmosphere
okay
um just briefly can you sketch out for
us in a little more detail
um
how you came to take mdma on that
at the wedding
oh well
it was evening time i think i
was a bit hungover from the day before
and
i can imagine those two
saw me and when they first dropped the
pill into my hand i thought it was like
a
supplement like a vitamin supplement to
make me feel better but um
no they they quickly said it was mdma
and i
kind of decided to throw caution to the
wind and just
try it
okay
you mentioned that you
traveled with mr dev and miss heard to
japan and berlin and possibly other
locations as well
can you tell us where else you traveled
with
them well
after the wedding we headed to australia
and why did you go to australia
because that's where johnny would be
shooting
pirates five
okay and approximately when
do you think you were in australia
i think that i flew with johnny and um
and jerry judge um and stephen and a few
others
um
i think that was february
um and um
and and johnny stayed in
a house
um
and stephen and i were based
like a 35 minute drive away on the
shoreline in the hotels
um
and i think amber flew in a while
afterwards
okay
uh you said you thought it was february
do you recall the year
yes i do 20 2015.
um
so just so we have the cast of
characters clear who who
from this group was in australia at this
point
um so we've got um on the plane that i
was on it was johnny
jerry judge stephen
deuters debbie lloyd
and myself
and maybe one of maybe one other
okay
um you mentioned the name there i don't
think we've heard before can you just
tell the jury quickly who debbie lloyd
is
okay
ladies and gentlemen of the jury we just
have to take a few housekeeping matters
up so we're just going to have you take
a recess for a few minutes okay so again
no outside research and don't talk to
anybody okay
so
all right miss studers i just had a
question for you have you been watching
the trial this past week
um i've seen clips of it online yeah
you've been watching so you have seen
parts of this trial
yeah okay and witness
testimonies yeah
you've seen him thanks all right does
anybody have any follow-up questions
um miss doodles um
have you been watching
it doesn't matter she's been watching
clips of witness testimony
all right your excuse ma'am you can have
your excuse okay thank you
i will i won't start the jury they'll
have to strike the testimony of miss
deuters there's a rule on witnesses mr
monas
i understand you're honest first word i
i i i i believe that i have no doubt in
my mind but this is the first you've
heard of it
have a good day ma'am thank you
i i i
hope i get the first time thank you
your next witness is going to be on
deposition right yes
okay all right did you want to take the
afternoon recess now before we
okay because i made your videos i'll
take afternoon recess and i'll instruct
the jury okay all right we'll take 15
minutes let's come back at 3 15.
um
yes
yes sir
sure
you're welcome
so
get somebody from here
anybody
okay
not yet
okay sure we'll take that up
all right
oh
oh goody
which exhibit is this
okay and make sure there are agreeable
redactions first
all right so 397 with these redactions
okay
all right that takes care of 397. now we
have
we're going to have to probably start
the video tonight and probably have to
finish it tomorrow morning correct by
the length of it
okay
and are the exhibits so you're going to
be switching back and forth again
i think i think in your honor that we're
just going to run this off of ours um i
believe the parties have worked out the
redactions okay i think i could be wrong
is there any objections to the exhibits
i don't think we've talked at all about
what exhibits were
coming in that's music to my ear i know
i know here
um i we didn't i don't think we had any
we've just exchanged the objections for
this so oh well in that in that case i
think we're handling introducing them to
the extent they get introduced and we'll
discuss any objections that's how i
understand it it would be okay
oh so we're just going to do objections
as we get to them that's fine i don't
have a problem with that that works out
okay so we'll start it when we're at
five o'clock we'll see where we are and
we'll find a good breaking point okay
all right
are we ready for the jury then
make sure you're ready i'm ready okay
all right you're ready
all right thank you
this is the first
now
there's a reason
all right thank you ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen the court is
striking miss gina deuter's testimony in
its entirety from the record okay
therefore the court further instructs
you the jury to disregard her testimony
in its entirety understand
all right thank you all right your next
witness
uh your honor we call dr david kipper by
video designation all right dr kipper
past and i represent amber heard
could you please provide your full name
david
allen
a-l-a-n hipper
k-i-p-p-e-r
and what is your business address dr
kipper
153
south last year
l-a-s-k-y drive
beverly hills
90212
california
um now you're a doctor correct
yes and an internist
yes
how long have you been practicing
medicine
since 1970
seven and um i noticed on your website
it says you provide concierge healthcare
what does that mean
that means i provide healthcare
on a retainer base
arrangement
what do you mean by retainer basement
arrangement
patients pay an annual fee
and all services are included and i'm
available 24 7.
now you also practice um
part of your practice is addiction
treatment is that correct correct
and you've written a book on addiction
yes
what's the title of the book the
addiction solution
and by addiction do you mean addiction
to drugs and alcohol
yes
is there any other addictions that you
uh practice treating
well there are behavioral addictions
but those are far less common
um
and in your practice you've dealt with
patients who've blacked out from drugs
or alcohol
yes
who is lisa bean
a former employee in my office
and what was miss bean's role in your
office
she was a receptionist
and how long did ms bean work for you
i don't have that specific
information i believe it was about three
years
in working with miss bean did you find
her to be honest
no actually
why was she not honest
she was inappropriate with certain
patients
beyond what i consider to be
professional
she discriminated in some regards
to some patients
she was
divisive in the office and created a lot
of problems with the other staff
oh
no she quit
and who is debbie lloyd
debbie lloyd is a nurse
that i have known for many years
who has worked with me on
home care
and addiction cases
and is is miss lloyd a
[Music]
an employee or a contractor with you
she's a contractor
does she still contract with you ms
lloyd
uh yes until recently she now has a new
position so
i'm not able to have her services at
this point
what was miss lloyd's role in mr depp's
care
she served as his rn as his registered
nurse
and was
all paid by you
for mr duff's care yes
so would it work that miss you would
bill
mr depp uh
for the care that miss that you gave and
miss lloyd gave
and then he paid from that
yes
and who is aaron burum
she's an rn
that was employed to help care for amber
was miss gorman also a contract nurse
yes
and
so did she did miss ballroom have any
role in mr depp's care
only if
if debbie was unavailable
aaron would step in and vice versa
and
and
and um did miss borum uh work with you
on anybody else besides mr depp or ms
heard
yes
does miss barham still work with you
this forum now has two little kids so
she's not really available
i understand i have two kids myself
um
when were you first contacted about
treating mr depp
somewhere in the spring of 2014
and do you recall
how you
who first referred you to mr deb
he was referred by another patient
did you talk to tracy jacobs at all
about mr beth
yes
what did you understand the business
relationship was between miss jacobs and
mr deb that she was his agent
why don't we put up uh alex can you put
up uh kipper 3 please
dr dr kipper do you recognize this
document
yes i do
and what is it
uh this is a an intake evaluation that i
had with mr depp regarding his treatment
and uh do you keep these uh notes in the
normal course of business
yes
and
the notes are meant to be accurate
yes
and did you take the notes or did
someone take them for you
i took these notes
is may 22nd 2014 the first time that you
met mr deb
no
when did you i'm sorry thank you your
honor i moved to admit uh defendants
exhibit 220 which is what dr kipper was
referring to there
any objection to 220 defendants 220.
foundation authentication hearsay
um
and uh
403.
all right
let me get
and your honor
dr kipper testified just now that these
are his
notes that he keeps in the regular
course of business of his meeting with
his initial consultation with mr depp
um which is what he does as a doctor and
you know and it's his
uh
medical records of his report with mr
dab so i think he's established the
foundation of that
all right
yes sir any response mr monas uh we're
just having a slight technical issue
pulling up the exhibit your honor i
apologize
uh your honor we would stand on the
hearsay and relevance objections um
there's a lot of material in this
document that is is not really
germaine to the issues in this case uh
at minimum and to the extent admitted it
should be admitted in redacted form um
in addition um it's not clear that
there's any hearsay exception
that would apply to everything in here
not everything in here is a statement of
a of a party opponent i don't believe um
and
finally the
medical records um
reflected here go go well beyond any any
possible
relevance to the issues in this case
it's it's not inappropriately we would
stand on that objection
all the statements in here are
statements of mr depp so they either be
a party admission or it's abusive
and and it's
dr dr kipper is it's his evaluation of
mr depp to
to to treat him for his
as you'll see his addictions so i think
this is all relevant there's no there's
no hearsay and if there is it meets the
exception is it's all mr depp's
statements
so it's a visit it's a business they've
not even argued it's but it's a business
it's clearly a business record it's
clear from the it's clear from the
document your honor that there's more in
here uh that the records here are at
minimum broader than it is
remained in this case i mean
this this goes well beyond any any
medical records that could conceivably
be relevant uh we would respectfully
submit uh to the issues in this case i
understand but i've given latitude as to
the family history and federal family
medical history so i'll allow 220 and
evidence okay okay
all right thank you
um
i guess can we publish it to the jury
not if you're watching oh um
well the way we've
that's fine your honor we can just have
him testify and then it's fine okay
thank you
mr depp prior to may 22nd 2014
i met him a couple months before that uh
as just an initial introduction
to discuss
possible treatment
and where were you when you first met mr
dab
he met me at my home office
and were there any did you have any
notes of that meeting at the home office
no
what did you discuss with mr depp at
that first meeting
at that meeting i discussed with him
my involvement in helping him with his
substance issues
and what substance issues did he did he
say he had
so to answer your question
this
mr depp was seeking treatment for
substance abuse
and wanted to
wanted to detoxify from his substance
abuse
did he mention did mr depp say what
substances he was trying to
detox from
yes and as indicated in this note
it was polysubstance so there was
alcohol opiates
benzodiazepines and stimulants
so
um you referenced the note which is um
kipper three in your meeting with
mr depp uh in the months before may 22nd
2014 mr depp was looking to
detox from alcohol opiates
benzo and cocaine
those
those substances were in his history the
substance that he was
at that point
concerned about uh and abusing were
opiates
and when you say he was concerned about
uh that the substance he was abusing was
opiates was this in the conversation
before may 22nd 2014.
i can't remember
so you had this initial conversation
with mr depp and then
um you had this initial consultation
with him a few months later is that
correct
yes that's correct
and you met with mr depp in boston
yes
and mr depp was filming a movie at the
time
yes
and in your notes you say
he had had a history of self-medicating
behaviors involving multiple substances
of abuse these include alcohol opiates
benzodiazepines
and stimulants cocaine
is that is that accurate what he told
you
yes that's in my
that statement's in my notes correct
okay
um
and with and in addition to opiates was
he was mr depp
uh
addicted to any other prescription drugs
no other than opiates no what is what is
roxy codon
it's an opiate
and what is what is adderall
adderall is a stimulant okay
was mr death uh addicted to adderall
no
what is xanax
xanax is a benzodiazepine
this first uh this first paragraph on
this page
um these are notes based off of
um
your discussion with mr depp
yes
and then on the second page where it
says physical examination that's just
what you conducted at the time
yes
and where it says impression on the
third page
that was your impression of mr depp at
the time of may 22nd 2014
yes
and under that the plan that that's
that's documenting your plan for mr depp
going forward
correct
mr depp paid for this visit
yes
when was the plan to start this
treatment of mr death
after his after he completed his current
film dr kipper do you recognize uh
kipper exhibit four
yes
and what are the what is kipper exhibit
for
it's a progress note
of
dated june 11
14 2014.
and and did you keep these notes in the
normal course of business
yes
and did you take these notes
yes and the notes are meant to be
accurate correct
yes
what is um you mentioned it before but
what is poly substance abuse
your honor
is multiple you can pause it thank you
it takes a second for it to catch up no
i understand okay thank you you're on
our move to the admission of the
defendant's exhibit two four six
two four six
do
and it's the same
type of medical record
uh that was just admitted uh for 220.
any objection but i'll give you a moment
to read it
thank you john just just one moment
uh understanding your honors uh ruling
on the last uh record i think we'll
we'll uh
we'll anticipate that the the exhibit
can come in
all right so i will take that as no
objection
all right 246 in evidence thank you
thank you
multiple substance
issues multiple substance
abuse
and you were going to be treating mr deb
for multi-substance abuse correct i was
going to be treating mr deb for opiate
issues
on the bottom of the first page where it
says impression that was your impression
of
mr depp at the time
where it says poly substance abuse
yes
and were these the drugs that mr depp
was taking at the time which is at the
bottom of page 1
of kipper 4.
i'm sorry can you
am i relating to
the
first uh entry under impression
it says uh what where is it what does it
mean where it says uh dopaminergic
imbalance with lithium 300 mg bid to be
increased to 300 m mgtid
those were medications that i had
planned to use
upon our
uh treatment
for all the medications that are in
kipper for under impression those are
medications you plan to use with mr deb
is that correct that's correct
[Music]
and on the next page where it talks
about opiate dependence
right we'll maintain on current norco
dosage tid until current filming is
completed in mid to late july
um mr depp agrees to undergo
detoxification with
clonidine
roboxin
bental and axial analytics i can't
pronounce it i'm sorry but is that
correct yeah you did a good job that's
that's that's what it says yes okay
what does tid mean
and mr depp was also going to undergo a
sobriety program is that correct
yes
and it says to be regularly drug tested
in my office how regularly was he to be
drug tested mr dapp
that was dependent upon his progress
and and my understanding of how he was
doing
and and um
if he was progressing well how often
would mr death be drug tested
okay you can answer
the answer is what i said it would
really depend um adam on how he was
doing at the time and how he was
progressing through his treatment do you
recall how many drug tests he gave mr
depp in 2014
no
you gave him at least one correct
yes
i believe so i'd have to i'd have to
check through my records okay
and and and deborah lloyd was going to
be mr depp's uh
nurse correct
correct
you can take down
kipper 4.
and can you put up kipper 5 please
and your honor we would move into
evidence uh plaintiff exhibit 40.
plaintiffs exhibit 40.
is there any objection
so you're
my understanding you're putting in you
want to move in
the entire document
we have uh we have redacted portions of
it
it's just 40.
um your honor
i would just have to look uh to make
i'm you know i'm generally okay with it
just i'd have to with 123 pages and then
there's certain redactions i just would
need to see
what was redacted i'm generally okay
with all right so the documents so i'll
enter it but with the reservation for
redactions that have need to be made
okay
all right that's fine
40.
so i don't know if they're thinking of
publishing it but i would ask that
they'd not publish it and just
let the video play
as he testifies to it and then we can
discuss what needs to be given the lack
of agreement uh confirmed agreement on
the redactions your honor i think that's
that's fine we should play the video do
that
thank you
okay
and
kipper5 is a long document
um
came out of your files um do you
recognize the document
yes
what is kipper5
it's a progress note dated
the 12th of june 2014.
so this this exhibit kipper 5 which i
will refer to throughout the um
your deposition
is a multi-page document that is
progress notes
throughout uh from multiple dates that
you pre that came out of your files
um
do you know who created these progress
notes
i created these progress notes
it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't miss lloyd
no these are my notes okay
all right
and you kept the notes in the normal
course of business
yes and again the notes are meant to be
accurate
yes
oh um
oh i'm sorry let's go back up
so this 6 13 14
that is that is your notes
correct okay
um
and it says um met with patient in his
apartment patient continues to be
pleasant and cooperative he stated that
he
initially
started taking opiates after some dental
work and became dependent on them you
were you recall that conversation with
mr dapp
yes those are my notes okay and it's
also accurate that patient is fearful of
coming off of opiates but knows what he
needs to do
yes that that reflects the conversation
i have okay and and patient also
expressed some emotional trauma which
causes him depression and anxiety
also true
and if we go to um
kipper 54
of
skipper exhibit five
these are the medications that
mr depp's assistant gave to you
correct
and
uh going down it's accurate where it's
at where it states um the mis that
patient states he currently takes
oxycodone 50 mg
vid and oxycodone on 30 mg at bedtime
yes that's correct
all right
i'm gonna scroll down a bit here
and we're going to go to
kipper 60
on kipper exhibit 5 the notes 4
6 22
14.
um
this is this is again a note that you
prepared
is this a note that you prepared dr
kipper i'm reviewing this okay sorry
yes
okay
um
and um
you see uh where it says in the middle
uh
patient spoke about his difficult
childhood and current mood swings
yes
um what did mr depp tell you about his
mood swings
that he that he had evanescent
changes uh in his mood
from
good to bad
and did he give any more information
about what a bad move what a bad um mood
would be
no it was implied that that would be
depression
sadness
about anger
that was not
that i don't remember him saying that
um and and if this note also said that
he'd been depressed for the past three
days
right above where we just looked
yes
and alex keep this up but uh but put out
uh kipper exhibit six please
honor we would move into evidence uh
depp exhibit 42
42
any objection to 42.
and this is another redacted document
council
so mine's not redacted yet correct i
don't see any reaction
we have we have we have a redacted copy
um which we can we can provide also uh i
believe this is unobjected to on our
exhibit
right
so pending redaction
well i have
the copy we had wasn't didn't have
reductions so i'm not sure
i
i non-redacted i'm happy to have it
included but i i would need to see the
redactions while reserved on on
redactions then as as we did with 40
okay so 42 in with redaction
understood yeah
decisions okay
[Music]
and dr kipper do you recognize kipper
exhibit six
yes
what is it
it's a summary of
the
treatment
and encounter with mr depp from june
22nd to june 24th of 2014.
and and that and and
you keep these notes in the normal
course of business correct
yes
and again they're meant to be accurate
correct
yes okay and these notes reflect that
you saw mr depp in boston again
correct okay um
and
in the second paragraph
you write uh we discussed the need for
compliance with his medications
we also discussed his nicotine habit and
agreed we would address this when we
completed the opiate and benzo
detoxification
mr depp's filming will be completed
around mid-july and we discuss the plan
detoxification mr depp prefers to do
this in his home in the caribbean
islands
the anticipated duration is between 10
to 14 days and he will be completely
isolated without
any professional or personal
obligations
uh does this reflect the discussion you
had with mr depp
yes it
does and
you also discuss that mr depp
understands that a nurse debbie lloyd
will assist me with this program and i
will initiate this withdrawal and
supervise daily
visiting him at the end of his treatment
to design the next steps in his therapy
um and this protracted therapy will
include a 12-step private counseling and
personal psychotherapy and couples
therapy with his fiance amber both are
in agreement to this plan
um does that reflect the conversation
you had with mr death yes and was
misheard at this conversation as well
i don't remember
but the last sentence implies that both
were in agreement
so it's very possible that she was but i
honestly can't remember
and um during this um
detoxification
um
who was going to be with mr deb at his
home in the caribbean islands
his fiancee amber
and the nurse
debbie lloyd
and whatever staff
members he had
where was miss lloyd going to be
each day in the caribbean islands
she was going to be on his property in a
separate area
and who was in midair stirring the
medications to mr dapp
miss lloyd was
giving these medications
and
and supervising that and there were
periods of time at night
during the evening early morning that
miss heard
uh was also helping with this
and would there be times where miss
heard was administering the medications
to mr depp without miss lloyd being
present
correct
under supervision but without being
present
and when you say under supervision what
do you mean by that
that miss lloyd would give
um the direction on how to provide these
medications it wasn't necessarily going
to be physically present there when the
medications were delivered to mr deb
correct
correct
and mr depp admitted to you that there
may be traces of cocaine since you've
been using the substance prior to the
initiation of this program correct
is this note correct what you what you
write here in kipper 6 that mr depp
admitted there may be traces of cocaine
yes
um okay can you um
let's just go to back to
exhibit five
and if we go to
um
you see the note of 6 24 14 at 1200
yes is 1200 at the time
yes and it said are these are these your
notes again these are my notes
dr kipper um
these 18 pages came from your production
and i'll represent to you that there
were no drug tests uh that i saw for
2014 or 2015 for mr depp you know why
that is
the only thing i can
the answer is no i can't i don't
understand that
um
we had a flood in our office
in
2014 october
the office above us
flooded our office and the basement
which is where we kept certain records
but i'm not sure which records relating
to mr depp would have been
involved in that but
um other than that no
would the uh
would drug test for mr deb for 2014 and
2015 would those also be kept
electronically
no
who did you work with um
to conduct the
drug test of mr deaf
yes i ordered the drug test
and what company did you work with
it appears that it's md lab that's the
lab we use
and the drug tests that we do have
they came from your files correct
correct and um
they're meant to be accurate correct
correct
and you would agree that
drug tests that you took of mr depp in
the 2016 through 2019 period showed mr
depp testing positive for cocaine
correct
correct
drug test showed mr depp
being positive for cocaine correct yes
correct okay and for thc he was mr depp
was also positive for thc correct
correct and for benzo is that correct
um
the answer would be yes i'm looking for
benzo
the answer would be correct because he
was maintained on benzos benzodiazepines
okay how long was was mr uh depth on
benzodiazepine
he was on benzodiazepines
pretty much throughout our relationship
during this period of time
was it one of the objectives to get him
off of benzozapatine
it was and we actually used a medication
to accomplish that
initially but he didn't tolerate that
medication very well
not everyone does
so he was put back on his benzos
on page
3 of exhibit 7
what what's being shown here
under
where it starts with cocaine
metabolites
this is
a listing of
substances
with
reference ranges
and i think
if you scroll down you'll see
his specific
analysis
related to that and on page four
robert wells was a name for mr depp is
that correct
correct
yes correct
and this this is a drug test for 11 21
16 correct
yes
and it what what is it showing mr debt
positive for
what's right
positive for cocaine
amphetamines
and benzodiazepines
and on page five
this is this is a test drug test for
november 21st 2016 correct
correct
and
it's showing
what drugs is it showing mr depp
was positive for
it shows cocaine benzodiazepine
cannabinoids and amphetamines
and again you did take
drug tests were taken of mr depp in 2014
and 2015 correct correct
now you had mentioned before
um
and the note said that the plan was for
mr depp to detox on his island in the
bahamas is that right correct okay
um
okay
and were you going to be going to to
the island at any point were you
planning to
yes
was it going to be throughout mr depp's
entire detoxification or
or when were you planning on being at
the island
i was planning to see him and did see
him
towards the beginning as we initiated
treatment
and towards the end when we were
transitioning from that treatment into
the next phase of his
now on 8 8 14
it says arrived on island today
plan is for patient to continue to take
routine meds through tomorrow at hs
at that time he will not
take his oxycodone and detox
medications will be initiated do you see
that
yes
okay is that you arriving at the island
or miss lloyd arriving at the island
that's miss floyd
so that so that 8 814 note is her note
correct
so some of these notes are hers and some
of these notes are yours
these notes going forward
are her nose appear to be her nose okay
what type of um
what type of uh
system were you putting these notes into
i don't understand your question
the notes just
appear to be continuous and you said
some of your your notes and some are her
nose
how they got cut together
because i put all of his treatment notes
together to be in one place
would miss lloyd type these notes or
were they handwritten
she would type these notes
and then and then who put them who put
them all together
i did okay
you see 8 9 14 patient expressed fears
of never feeling normal without his
drugs
do that i see that um was was that did
mr depp ever express that to you
yes in some form he he
discussed that with me
[Music]
hmm
um
hold on one second
oh sorry
you see
uh
at kipper 7 kipper 71 uh where it says
md's flight has been canceled
arrangements are being made for him to
arrive on the island on 8 12 14.
yes i see that okay so is is it accurate
that you arrived at in the mr depp's
island on august 12 2014
is that accurate yes that's accurate
did you go to assess mr depp on august
15 2014 according to these notes that's
correct
and by the way fiance has misheard in
these notes correct
yes
and patient is mr dab correct correct
and this is a kipper 77 on on kipper
five texts from fiance the patient is
upset and irritable
md and rn want to assess
the patient
is that accurate that you came to see mr
depp at one o'clock in the morning yes
and after receiving a text from miss
heard
correct
mr depp the note says he state he being
mr depp
states he had a fight with beyonce and
his questioning whether or not he can
emotionally and physically physically
handle detox you recall this
conversation
i can't remember that conversation but i
do know that he was struggling at that
point
and how was he struggling
again he was frustrated he was
uncomfortable physically
dr kipper this is a
email
well he recognizes this document
i do
and what is what is kipper eight
this is an email that i sent to his
sister christie
christy dembrowski is mr depp's sister
correct
and you sent this email to ms dombrowski
on august 18th at 7 54 am correct
correct
this email was shortly after you had met
with uh
mr depp in the note we just discussed
correct
oh 7 54 pacific so um
it was sometime in the morning in the
bahamas correct
i guess i i don't have that calculator
in front of me
either it's either three or four hours
ahead so it's either 10 54
maybe it's 11 54 in the morning
correct i i guess that's right and i
assume that's right
okay
and and
you wrote this and why did you write
this email to ms dombrowski
we were planning to transition back to
los angeles
we had completed the initial phase
of his detoxification
and i wanted to update her as to my
uh impressions on how he was doing and
how we would proceed going forward
and you wrote this to miss dombrowski
because you were concerned about mr dap
is that correct
i wrote this so that she was aware of
where we were in the process of his
treatment
and you wrote this after he had an
incident with miss heard correct
i did not witness the incident
i wrote this after we were called to see
him
because there was an alleged incident
but he clearly was uncomfortable at that
time when we came to see him
and again we were getting ready to
transition
off of the island and i wanted uh
chrissy to have a clear understanding of
where we were at that time
can we pause i was going to move forward
and then at 12
30 thank you i was going to move for the
admission of defendants exhibit 268.
268.
and your honor we're going to have a
substantial hearsay and speculation
objection to this exhibit
this is a communication
from dr kipper to a third party it's
hearsay from start to finish and not
within any exception to say nothing of
the fact that it contains
speculation okay i think there's certain
hearsay in the first part in the first
paragraph and in the
third
on the second page but the the rest of
it is is dr kipper's
impressions um of of mr depp it's not a
court statement offered for the truth
your honor it's hearsay i'm going to
sustain this to hear say okay okay thank
you
you and dennis lloyd
met with mr depp
uh yes according to these notes
yes okay and do you know was this now in
the bahamas or was this back in los
angeles
i i need to go back to the date not the
time can you scroll up thank you
8 2014
and
i'm just looking at my calendar
yes we were now back in los angeles
and in the 12th in the notes on 12 30 on
august 20th mr depp stated he was done
with the process and no longer wanted md
and rn services you see that
yes you recall mr def telling you that
yes
and you recall mr depp saying that there
was tension between him and miss heard
yes
was the plan for miss her to take a few
days for herself
yes
and mr depp wanted is it true that mr
depp wanted to stop taking all the
medications you were providing him
uh yes that's reflected in this note
um now you mentioned you had um
you did text with mr death on occasion
correct
i believe so but i
i really can't remember any specific
time or
message that i sent to him
dr kipper um mr def has produced
a number of texts in this litigation
between
you and him and they're in this chart
here and we're not going to go through
all of them i promise you um
but i'm just going to i want to ask you
about a few of them um and we'll do this
kind of throughout the deposition
um
here
okay
and
um
on 8 21 2014 it says dr david kipper
this 310 phone number was that your
phone number at the time
yes
okay and this is a text from you
that says um to mr depp that says glad
you're better today respect you as much
as i love you you're impossible not to
love but an easier job not to respect
you're making my job a pleasure and
honor and a few sleepless nights stop
firing me i know what i'm doing
you recall sending that text to mr cap
yes
okay
how long have you been working with mr
depp at this point
as of august 21st 2014
and can you define by working with him
are you talking about specifically the
detox are you talking about our initial
meeting
for one second how many months
your honor um
as i as i mentioned in the deposition
uh defendants exhibit 1063 is a
long list of text messages between dr
kipper and mr depp a number of which are
going to be testified to today
or monday and i would just ask that the
ones that they testify to we would
provide
in a redacted form which would just be
that just the text that they're
testifying to and it would be for a
number throughout i can get up each time
but i was hoping i wouldn't have to do
that uh your honor i think we're going
to have to maintain a hearsay objection
it's it's it's a text by text issue
whether it falls within any exception um
so we're not going to be able to agree
that the entire document comes in it's
possible that some may come in um but i
think that's going to be something that
needs to be worked out between council
afterwards so we can reserve it he's
still going to testify to it because
we've already got right i understood
your honor the testimony can come in but
that doesn't mean the document itself is
admissible i can reserve on 10 to 1063
and we can figure out the you redaction
so
about four months okay and you write
stopped firing me
in that four months how many times had
mr death tried to fire you
uh that was i believe that was
the first time
and again this was in reference to him
not wanting to proceed and not wanting
our help this is actually i'm sorry this
is the second time
because the first time was on the island
just as we were getting ready to leave
that he did not want to proceed he
didn't think he could do it
that changed after a conversation he was
back on board
and this came from uh i think followed
that incident that you we just referred
to in the notes
where we were asked to come and visit
with them
and
where he didn't want to proceed and
again at the end of that visit he was
back on board
uh
[Music]
okay
now
on august 24th 2014
shows a text when it shows him that's mr
depp to you david kipper
and mr depp wrote
forgot to tell you had a hopefully very
positive and free of ego squawk with
amber last night that went very well dot
dot dot and then i shot a few negroes
and a club on sunset boulevard so far so
good dot dot dot
do you recall this text from mr depp
no
okay
um is was that mr def's typical language
again i don't recall this specific email
so
that may be
that may have been a uh
an attempted humor
dr kipper uh kipper10 is and you
recognize this document
uh no
but i'm
i'm looking at it
um
let me ask you this you recall of arrows
arc at icloud.com
um ms heard's email address
um
i assume that by looking at this
document
exhibit five uh
101
at 9
22 14 at 1 25. you see it says um
received text from patients stating that
he had been in an argument with fiance
and she had a quote nasty freak out and
would like
nurse to give him some quote some
[ __ ] knockout yum yum
rn instructed patient to take
prn neurotin 300 mg prn and seroquel 50
mg and that rn was on her way you see
that
yes okay
and this is a note from miss lloyd
correct
okay
um and then it says at 3 30 upon
arriving at the home patient was sitting
in kitchen with scraped and bloody
knuckles on
our hand meeting his right hand correct
correct
patients stated he punched whiteboard in
kitchen after fight
um
patients stated he'd been texting his
friend explaining why he didn't show up
to play music and beyonce got upset he
was not giving her enough support and
the fight escalated from there
call the md at 1 45 and instructed to
give a stat order of ambient mg to help
patient get to sleep
as he has an early work day
um do you recall miss lloyd telling you
about um
or visiting mr depp
and him having
bloody knuckles and a scraped hand
specifics i i'm reading the note you're
reading and yes i remember there was an
incident
and an incident where mr depp had
had scraped and bloody knuckles on his
hand
as indicated in the note yes
i did not i did not see bloody knuckles
uh i did not see a punch board this was
a communication that i received through
the notes from this world
and do you recall if you had a com it
does say you were called do your call if
you had a conversation with ms lloyd
about
yes i i recall having spoken about
there had been an incident i don't
recall the specifics of that
conversation
okay
uh on on uh kipper five
at
ten
at the date of
10 14
to show you there which is on kipper 110
of paper five
and then going down to
1930 it says patient finished filming
and was extremely agitated leaving the
set patient kicked in the door of his
trailer and refused to speak to
director patron was verbally aggressive
to another person on the set
for no apparent reason her md patient
takes xanax two milligrams to reduce his
agitation at this time
you recall that dr kipper
i do remember this
this entry yes
you remember being told then mr depp
kicked in a door of his trailer and
refused to speak to his director correct
i don't remember the specifics but i do
remember there was some um disagreement
between mr depp and the director
and and
where it says per md patient is to take
xanax two milligrams to reduce his
agitation at this time is that an
increase of xanax that he was to receive
yes
and you see at 10 15 at 6 45 it says
patient awake and states he slept from
uh 2200 to
430 patient continues to be agitated
about work and is verbalizing having
desires to escape with drugs
um
do you recall seeing this note
i re i
yes
okay and you recall miss lloyd telling
you this about mr deb
you can't remember if she told me that
he wanted to
use
but i do remember her uh telling me that
he was upset
and is that reflected in the note of 845
md informed
of mine
right here 8 45.
okay
the note's accurate that md information
state of mind and continued agitated
he's on his way to assess patient yes
and then at 12 30
this patient had fallen asleep and is
now awake talking with md it has been
decided patient is under too much stress
as it would be best for him to stay home
and rest today
you see that yes you recall having a
conversation with mr depp
about his press
yes i do do you recall anything that mr
depp told you
you can't
i remember he was very upset i don't
remember the specifics of that
conversation but i remember he was upset
and how was mr depp displaying his that
he was very upset
he expressed himself very well that he
had
he and the director had some
misunderstanding and that he was upset
about it was mr depp yelling
no
was he was he doing anything to display
his being upset other than his words
just his words
don't um
doubt the accuracy of this of this note
though do you
i can say that the note was written and
and i believe it was good reporting
i i trusted my my nurses that they would
report what they were told
after the opiates
not for the opiates is that what you
said correct
a positive for cocaine for instance yes
now
on
november 17th
2014
in 2014 mr def texted you
and said
i have been to see amber downtown yeah
yeah interesting to say the least wow
anyway i'm still awake and don't foresee
slumber arriving anytime soon to this
broken instrument of a squash situated
atop my shoulders
i would love to speak whenever you have
get a minute dear david though honestly
if i were you debbie and or aaron i
i would
capital letters run for the [ __ ]
hills three exclamation points i love
you doc dot dot dot cannot thank you
enough for all you've done not only for
me and my poor pack of wolves and my
sweet
capital letters [ __ ] brave mikey dot
dot dot these are the things that remind
us that life should be a [ __ ] gas i'm
waist deep in big muddy here dot dot dot
hit me when you're drunk dot dot dot
it'll be far less boring
love you long time brother dot dot dot
and of course the beautiful and luminous
chanel dot dot dot and buy now
eight foot six sam exclamation points
mucho mucho
dot dot dot from the from those of us
who are not as others x jd you recall
this text from mr depp
no i don't but clearly i see that i
received that text
uh alex can you put up um
kipper 13 please
so
do you recognize dr kipper this email
uh chain between you and colin cowan
i don't remember it but i'm refreshing
myself
with what you're showing me
who is colin cowan
he's a psychologist
that i had referred amber to see
are the is there any um dr kipper are
there any um
ethical rules to report uh reports of
violence if you were to be told of the
violence
if i were to see the violence
i would be obligated
to
i would be obligated to
make some reporting i never saw any
violence
and you didn't report either mr death or
misheard correct
because you didn't see your testimonies
you didn't see any violence between
from history
you never saw violence between the two
of them okay you'd heard reports but
never saw you never saw it as your
testimony all right
dr kipper do you recognize kipper 14
which
it looks like is an email between you
and alan blaustein
yes i i i recognize this okay
and
who is who is alan blaustein
alan blasting is the psychiatrist
that i referred
uh mr depp to and when you wrote this uh
email as of march 1st 2015 was it your
understanding that mr depp was in
australia at the time
yes
at some point you flew to australia is
that correct in this march 2015 time
frame
yes
was that the pl were you always planning
to fly to australia
to visit with mr depp in in march of
2015
no
i i hadn't planned on it
what what made you fly to australia
he had wanted to see me
uh he had just wanted to check in he
wanted
he wanted he wanted my
company at that point
he being johnny depp
yes
do you know when you uh
arrived in australia
um
no i don't i can't recall
miss lloyd had gone with mr depp to
australia
yes
she wasn't staying with mr depp correct
no no she was not you know how far away
miss lloyd was from mr depp
in terms of time to get from where she
was staying to mr depp's house
i would
i would guesstimate somewhere between
20 minutes to 30 minutes
and when you
went to australia
how far away were you for mr deb
in terms of time exactly the same
were you and ms lloyd in the same hotel
yes
actually that isn't true i was in a
hotel
around the corner from where
the nurses were
um and in kipper 5 at kipper 157 you see
this note for 3 7 15 at 11 30
11 30. it says md received a text
message from client that he had been
arguing with wife and that he cut it had
cut his finger
according to patient his assistant and
security were
were on their way to pick him up you see
that
yes
uh and whose note is this
that would be from miss lloyd
and is this note
accurate
yes
it's it's accurate okay
um now going back to kipper9
um
a moment
7790
here shows a text from mr depp
to you on march 7th 2015
at
5 p.m
and it says
hi
[ __ ] man had another one
i cannot live like this
she is as full of [ __ ] as a christmas
goose i'm done
no more all capital letters three
exclamation points
the constant insults the demeaning
belittling most heartbreaking smu that
is only released from a malicious evil
and vindictive [ __ ]
five exclamation points but you know
what two question marks capital letters
far more
hurtful than her venomous and degrading
endless quote educational ranting dot
dot dot three
question marks is her hideously and
purposely hurtful tirades and her
goddamn shocking treatment of the man
she was meant to love above all dot dot
here's the real deal mate
dot dot dot her obsession with herself
two question marks it is far more
important dot dot dot she is
capital letters so [ __ ] ambitious
three exclamation points she's so
desperate for success and fame dot dot
dot that's probably why i was acquired
mate dot dot dot two exclamation points
although she has capitalized hammered me
with what a sad old man
has been i am
three dot three dots cowan has done me
the most cruel of favors dot dot dot i'm
so very sad dot dot dot i cut the top of
my middle finger off dot dot dot what
should i do exclamation point two
question marks except of course go to a
hospital dot dot dot i'm so embarrassed
for jumping into anything with her dot
dot dot capitalize [ __ ] the world three
exclamation points jd
do you recall this text from mr deb
i i don't recall the text but i do
recall him reaching out uh after this
incident
this this text is this text um
a typical type of text you would receive
uh in retrospect and in reading this no
i think it reflected the fact that he
was injured
right and mr depp told you in the text i
cut the top of my middle finger off
correct
uh that's what it says
and then and then you responded call me
you see that that's the next text
yes
okay yes
and did mr depp call you
uh i can't recall if he called me but i
know that i went to the residence okay
and did you go with miss lloyd
yes okay and back to kipper 5
at 1300
it says on march 7 2015 patient was
having a hard time leaving the house so
security suggested the md and rn go to
house to see patient upon arrival the
house patient was sitting in car ready
to leave md assess patient's finger and
we'll spend more time with patient at
the location he's being moved to
so did you see mr depp in the house
yeah i saw mr depp outside the house in
the car okay so this no this note is
accurate correct
yes was mr depp intoxicated when you saw
him
i don't
was mr depp coherent
uh yes quite
i don't recall what he said i remember
that he was very clear in speaking to me
okay
what did he other than his finger what
did he look like
he looked like someone who just had part
of his finger
taken off
anything did he did what did the rest of
his hands and arms look like
uh nothing unusual
what'd the house look like
the house was a
mess anything rc can describe about the
house
there were things on the floor
there were
things that had been
uh
thrown around it looked like they were
just things were out of order in that
house
what what rooms did you see what rooms
did you look at in the house
i was in the kitchen
and
i believe i went downstairs
i don't really remember i saw it was
more of the same that things looked
out of place
were
did it look like there was a painting on
the wall someone had
written things on the wall
no i do
it did look to me like there was blood
on the wall
not an actual painting
how long were you in the house for
10 minutes 15 minutes
and what were you doing in the house
i wanted to see
what happened i was trying to figure out
what happened
did you talk to miss heard
i did or what did miss heard say
again i can't recall specifics other
than they had a fight
and
the specifics beyond that i don't i
don't remember
before seeing mr depp that day when was
the when had you seen mr debt previously
i i don't remember
you know if it was the day before
i can't remember
do you remember if this was the first
time you saw mr depp since your arrival
at in australia
again i can't remember
dr kipper i'm showing you what's been
marked as
uh
keeper 15.
um
and my question is do you recognize this
email
yes i do okay
and
it's an email and you told miss lisa
bean to please print for the chart see
that at the top
yes okay so that you is being printed
for mr depp's chart is that correct
correct
and uh raja sahani emailed you you see
that
yes
and he writes thank you for your time
david attaches a copy of my notes
for you to use as necessary
robert wells
and robert walls is mr depp correct
correct
and this was from march 8 2015 correct
yeah is it accurate that he that his
hand that heavily contaminated hand and
fingers with dirt grime
yeah thank you i was going to move for
the admission of defendants exhibit 370.
three seven zero three seven zero yes
just one moment your honor
and your honor we would uh
your honor we would maintain our
objections on grounds of hearsay
and your yeah and the other objections
asserted in our in our um objections to
the exhibits this is an email
communication between uh two non-parties
to this case um it's here say it's not
within any exception certainly not
within the medical exception um and it's
not admissible i think it is in the
medical exception because it's from one
doctor to another doctor to treat mr
depp's hand
uh sustained injections here thank you
that's accurate
is there anything other than the
coherent here that you find that's
inaccurate
uh no the rest of that seems accurate
okay
and um
when you saw um
miss heard at the house uh
in this march 7th 2015 time frame
um
did she seem like she was on um
was she coherent
she was
coherent dr kipper do you recall seeing
kipper
16
from the gold coast university hospital
yes i do
and
when do you recall seeing this this note
at the the time on march 8th 2015 or
around then
it was around then this this was the
emergency room doctor that saw him and
then he gave him sort of temporary care
and then he was referred to
mr depp was referred to the other doctor
that we spoke of before this
who was the surgeon who was the hand
surgeon i believe did you talk to this
this doctor who wrote this note
yes i was present when mr death was
being examined and treated
and at this point you were as of march
14 2015 you were telling mr depp that
you weren't going to be able to treat mr
depp anymore is that correct
the purpose of this note was to make
sure that he was strictly compliant
with everything
[Music]
because he needed to have his finger
reconstructed and i wanted to be sure
that he was following our guidelines
for
the
the drug treatment
mr depp was not following your protocol
as of march 1st 2015. correct
um yes i had concerns
mr depp was not following your protocols
that you were giving him as of
march 14 2015 correct
correct
dr kipper
do you recognize
kipper17
yes
so you were withdrawing your care for mr
death at least as of march 15 2015
correct
i was withdrawing my care if he did not
comply
and as of march 15 2015 doc mr depp was
not complying correct
it was mr depp
can you pause it again i'm sorry
thank you
um
move for the admission of defendants
exhibit 391
and your honor we would maintain our
objections on grounds of hearsay
um
relevance and uh 403.
it's it's
uh it's here say not with any exception
it's a communication um from a third
party made not a missile
it's it's a it's not here say it's a
letter from dr kipper that doesn't have
any hearsay in it and it's it's
well it's hearsay because it's a letter
from him out of court
i mean it's not offered for the truth of
what happened it's offered for what you
know what was occurring with mr what was
occurring with mr depp at the time of
march 15th well that's true by
definition truth
that's being offered for the truth
it's offered for notice of when mr that
when dr kipper was
not continuous care mr dap i'll sustain
the objection
thanks
compliant
as of march 14th
the answer is the answer is yes he was
not compliant and the problem at hand
no pun intended was he was about to have
surgery
and for him to have surgery on a finger
he needed to be strictly compliant with
what his medications were what his
behavior was
and i did not think he was stable for
surgery
and i could not clear him for surgery
and that was what provoked the letter
right and and mr depp was been breaking
promises to remain sober correct
correct
and then
did you ever uh stop
your care of mr depp
there was a
i believe and i'm fuzzy on the time
frame but there was a short period of
time
after sending that note
before he
connected back with me asking me to take
care of him and
promising me compliance
was mr depp compliant
with the program going forward after
march
15
2015.
he was compliant
around his surgery and post-operative
period
and then he became uncompliant again
i would have to refer to my notes but i
don't remember him being
i don't remember him being out of
control i remember him being
you know compliant with what we needed
him to do there were times
when mr depp sort of went underground
some of that time was when he was out of
the country
and was hard to connect to
but i do not recall him going off the
reservation as far as
his drug and alcohol
issues
you recall him testing positive for
cocaine after march of 2015
i believe that i believe so i can't tell
you specifically when okay
uh going back to kipper9 uh there's a
text message from mr depp to you on
march 19 2015
and he says my my sincere most sincere
apologies to you doc i understand your
decision based on my immunity to do the
right thing and i truly thank you for
your concern i must apologize for not
having had the presence of mind to
respect the man who has been the most
kind and who has done more for me than
anyone ever there was no call for my
spineless and base behavior toward you i
honestly understand the reasons for your
concerns in your letter and
and can save you now they are no longer
an issue thank you for everything i've
chopped off my left finger as a reminder
that i should never cut off my finger
again i love you brother johnny uh do
you recall this text from mr depp
yes and is this the text do you recall
where mr depp was saying that he would
uh be compliant going forward
yes
okay you're basing it off of this text
was there any other conversations with
mr death
we did i know we had a conversation at
some point around that time
that validated this message
and going to uh back to kipper 5
which are
again the notes
and we're going to go to kipper 167.
and at um
for 413
at 1 500.
the note at the bottom
says
patient is in good spirits and said he's
not smoked marijuana in three days
states he feels majority of his issues
with his wife have been from him using
drugs and alcohol patient states he'll
no longer sneak slash use and wants to
enjoy clarity
uh do you see that note i see that note
and who is that note from
you or ms lloyd
that's from miss floyd okay did miss
lloyd report this to you
in this node okay
and there's no no reason to question the
accuracy of the node correct
correct
now
at dep 168
um
12 15
it says at on on april 15 12 15 arrived
the patient's home assistant was in
hallway informed rn the patient was in a
bad mood and told assistant he did not
need anything from him today
rn was left let him home by security and
knocked on the patient's bedroom door
to let him know she was there patient
screamed what
um
are an informed patient she was just
letting him know she was there and would
be downstairs
um
rn
a little more down arron left property
and informed md of the events
uh do you recall miss lloyd telling you
about
um
these events of april 15
2015.
my memory is refreshed by looking at
this note yes
and and mr death
yelled at miss lloyd is that right
i'm not sure he yelled at miss
lloyd i think he just yelled
i wanted to be heard
i can't say i wasn't there
there's a text from mr depp to
you on april 15 2015
and he says my dear brother david if
there's a god then i'm positive it's you
thank you darling man i'm fine i didn't
know it was debbie until i'd already
thrown my voice toward the door thought
it was stephen who is
no small cauldron of hot water
two exclamation points i'll call debbie
to apologize
dot dot my boundless love and infinite
thanks
so you recall that he texted you and
called miss lloyd to apologize
no i don't recall that specifically
i'm reminded by this note but i don't
recall that specifically
now mr depp sent you a text
on june 28 2015
that says thank you my darling kipper
all those technical abbreviations left
me flux something in the dark
for your exclamation points soon soon i
must see you and just hang out three
exclamation points my deformed finger
and i have no friends three exclamation
points by the way dot dot dot amber and
i have been absolutely perfect for three
[ __ ] months solid four exclamation
points i've locked my monster child away
in a cage within and it has [ __ ] work
for exclamation points we're goddamn
best friends now three exclamation
points amazing three exclamation points
big love to you my brother dot dot dot
jd you see that
yes
and and what do you recall you were
what is refreshed of your memory
that there was obviously there was
concern that he was taking more xanax
and he should have been
and
i
needed him to
tighten that up and to go back to what
he was prescribed
and also there's a reference here
to the phone calls um
had asked him not to
respond or not and not to engage in
these phone calls because those were
all that always precipitated
uh problems between the two of them
when they were in this when they were in
a bad phase
phone calls between mr depp and miss
heard
correct
and mr depp
responds on july 1st 2015
and says i am and have been at peace for
the last three to four months it's been
amazing but she's somehow locked into
this very unpleasant and belittling mode
in the last three days the accusations
the verbal abuse and insults stooping to
one
the most unjust you haven't changed you
[ __ ] desperate hypocrite you didn't
you didn't out the monster away you're
full of [ __ ] you're pathetic fraud man
you know how hard i have worked to put
that [ __ ] in its cage and i did
that me i took all those other problems
and rid myself of them there's a whole
lot more i won't bore you with it the
xanax takes the edge off just a little
you know me
it would take
more than a few to really affect me
seroquel scares me for the reasons i i
were off of it
if you're worried about the xanax
prescribing something different but with
more potency i don't take them all that
often just when the brain is inundated
with this horrible badgering and half
truths from my wife
uh by
by the wsy i don't know if he meant by
the way um
do you recall this text
um
again
i do looking at it yes okay and mr depp
again used the term uh monster shark
yes
and mr depp
goes on in this text he says by the way
um
he sends another
sorry here's my by the way colin should
be run out of town and utter shane he's
a [ __ ] sump who's done absolutely
nothing but giving her the verbosity
that she off that she uses
that she uses ever whatever she feels
like she must explain to me the
psychology of life through exclamation
points ludicrous three exclamation
points yes sir cowan should be shot in
places no one wants to be shot in three
exclamation points he's a goddamn
charlatan big time three exclamation
points i'm not going to continue to pay
the [ __ ] yes man to do nothing but
stare as her tits and agree with
everything she spews
dot dot tell him to tell he's leaving
the business or something or i would or
i too will become a regular client
whether i am welcome or not three
exclamation points thanks and so sorry
i loved gu
you recall your call mr depp uh
informing you that he was upset with dr
cowan
yeah
yes i i
remember
clearly that he was upset with dr cowan
at a certain point
you know do you recall this text message
from mr
depp that i just read to you
yes when in reading it i do okay
all right you weren't going to pause it
looks like a good time to break it it's
five o'clock
perfect thank you all right any
objection to breaking there for the
weekend
all right
all right ladies and gentlemen we'll
pick up with this testimony on monday
since uh i'm not going to see you for
three days i just want to reiterate the
same jury instruction i gave you in the
beginning of the case when you were
first impaneled not all of it but some
of it i just want to make sure you
understand for the weekend that you're
not to read anything about the case
you're not to watch anything about this
case you're not to listen to anything
about the case this applies to
television newspapers magazines the
internet and any online sites further
you're not to read watch or listen to
anything about the case on any social
media networking sites such as twitter
facebook instagram snapchat or similar
sites
in addition you must not communicate
with anyone about the case whether in
person over the phone by email text or
instant messaging or by any other
electronic or non-electric electronic
means this includes your friends family
co-workers acquaintance and strangers i
also instruct you that you cannot do any
research or make any inquiries about
this case whether online or by any other
means what you learn about this case is
limited to limited to what you learn in
the four walls of this courtroom when
proceedings are underway all right so
have a good weekend and we'll see you
bright and early monday okay thank you
uh
all right and for the litigants i'll see
you back on monday please no posting on
social network networking sites and
don't talk to the press all right
and for the attorneys i will see you
tomorrow at 10 a.m for a long day and
i'm sure you've been doing your homework
right so we should be able to get
through a lot of deposition objections
right
perfect all right thank you all right
we'll see you tomorrow then thank you
you